to
what is up people of the world it's
wednesday
september 14th
and we're off the rails
um
here is
[Music]
that's the game
oh no
we're trying to reach across the aisle
to the tater tots i'm throwing my hair
back people people people
people people people
no
[Music]
whoa
shut up
[Music]
i
thank you
[Music]
of course there's more that's way too
sure
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay the troll doll
are we done nope we're not done hello
hello oh no that's not ninja's turn
all right guys
ethan klein boys over there
we love you ninja
[Music]
wow
wow wow thank you guys welcome everybody
i'm so glad you all are here thank you
zach and what i assume is ian on that
beautiful collaboration
audio and visual journey to the center
of space
beautiful touching stuff here today's
episode is sponsored by
honeyandstamps.com
today i'm also drinking strawberry
energy
sup nation what's up nation gamer sup
what's up sup sup
oh damn everybody's hitting that sub the
last time we had a sup show
people were like i love
i love sucked up ethan because it gets
crazy when i drink this yeah i'm a
little scared today so energizing
mm-hmm
i think i'm putting too much in here
tell everyone to put two scoops on the
back it says one scoop you're trying to
give me a heart attack one scoop per
eight ounces that's way more than eight
ounces add one yeah it is unrelated can
i give a shout out to the fan who i
accidentally let in the instagram live
shout out i
accidentally let a fan in and i had to
end the stream and restart it shout out
sorry i hung up on you god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did they get opportunity to say anything
uh they did not yeah they just said
and excitement
all right well shout out you know stuff
happens but we love you
um we were just arguing uh not arguing
but we're live right now
on tick tock and that's when all the
tater tots come out it's super
interesting they're like dedicated fans
i mean
our whole highlights channel is like 100
tater tots i mean they are funding
they are funding our whole highlights
channel it's wonderful but
you know i think it's time we start
reaching out to the tater tots out here
uh i can be your daddy i can teach you
how to be a man i'm gonna teach you how
to get laid all that stuff man trust me
no trust me i got advice i i'm
successful
shut up i'm matt hey i'm fat and
successful imagine what you could do if
being
fit and and and you know what i mean
shut the [ __ ] up it's unattractive
andrew stopped is it about you you're
not even allowed on tick tock my neck
sorry
i'm talking to tick tock sorry guys
he's not allowed in here
yeah but i am planning oh thank you dan
i really do want to plan an alpha
segment um that's coming up on friday
because
dan's fixing my mug you guys could
probably hear that
yeah dan's just tightening the the nub
there okay very good thank you dude
because you know i realized that like
our channel is having a problem okay
the win the ladies we have a great
relationship with the ladies we love the
ladies
actually i think we're great with
everyone but like alpha nation the
manosphere they all hate my guts
ladies and gentlemen and so we need to
reach out i need to prove to them that
i'm a masculine man and that we hold the
same values in that
that i can be an ally and a daddy to
them
so on friday we're going to begin a new
series of alpha
segments to reach across the aisle
graciously
magnanimously
to get this to get some alphas going
yeah but anyway obviously the obvious
question for everybody here is how is
everyone's butthole doing after
wednesday
the chip challenge
uh it's okay
it's been rough
yeah so wednesday we all did the one
chip challenge by the way that episode
was so much fun watching it back i went
back a lot of times and watched certain
parts of it
so i think the show was a hit
oh yeah it was really fun to watch back
living it was a different experience but
watching back is great i watch it back a
few times abey you said that you
wouldn't do it for a million dollars
in that moment i was a hundred percent
serious and now
i do think on it stop you did it
it's complicated bro you do it for 500
stop there's a extra there's one left we
can prove it right now i would not do
that for a thousand dollars and i know
you give me a thousand i'm not doing it
hell no
how's your butthole how's your recovery
just tell me everything uh it's okay i
got a root canal yesterday and like
midway through the dentist i started to
feel my stomach bubbling i'm like no god
please no but thankfully you didn't hit
me until later at night you know like i
was [ __ ] fire
that's so lucky because yeah basically
all of yesterday i had like emergencies
where i had to run to the toilet
and it was hot i mean it was hot it
wasn't
as hot but it was hot you know what i
mean yeah
it was it was bad i just left the bidet
on
to just
like while i was [ __ ] i know that
sounds disgusting but just to cool my
[ __ ] like while you were [ __ ]
like in between what are you talking
about yeah you were [ __ ] into a jet
of water i was letting the jet go i turn
it off less them out and turn it back on
okay but not [ __ ] and squirting at
the same time no no no no no in pulsate
mode yeah yeah
i'm [ __ ] my pants it's a beautiful
harmony of [ __ ] and water it was just
back to back
they should set that show up outside the
bellagio
yeah lina how are you i mean uh the
beast mode absolutely destroyed somebody
pointed out you beat sean evans score
which is pretty incredible he did five
minutes i saw that that's pretty crazy i
am proud of myself
i didn't have as bad of a reaction as
abe but also for me the day after it did
mess me up a little bit in the morning
and then that's it yeah that was like a
one day thing anyone else want to share
there
it was just the first night for me that
was the rough one and then i'm good now
day after i was fine everything's back
to normal
pretty good and poor zach he had
obviously eight more than all of us so
yeah i was worried about you all night
well funny enough i ended up catching up
a little cold
i don't know from that but um
yeah
all right thank you zach for the chip
you poisoned me
uh but did you feel any ramifications
from the grain of corn that you ingested
no i did not take it no we were everyone
was really worried about you i was
worried about david
yeah so true yeah and well ian got hit
real hard too ian i mean you were you
were dead basically at the end of the
last episode
it was just the stomach just the
punching of the stomach and the
intestines it felt
very normal and natural and
can't have any lasting effects i'm sure
on the body but
uh no i
yesterday i took such a like a
i'm i'm sorry i took such a hot [ __ ]
yeah you go ahead and i just
finished and i just
crawled into the shower
and just put it as cold as possible
and just sat in there
sam was not home at the time
so yeah go on i'm learning this now yeah
it was rough i went home a little early
yesterday
yeah sam told me you weren't eating
which made me concerned because i i
think putting stuff in your stomach is
good to protect it you want to dilute
the spice that's in there you know what
i mean
yeah
yeah it was not fun
would you do it again
for a million bucks yeah
what wouldn't we do for a million bucks
i mean maybe
you know
i don't know
that
can put that to the test someday
but um okay that was fun yeah and just
honestly
[Music]
the person we should all be worried
about is zach obviously who
didn't eat this whole thing but just the
tip of it this piece here
[Laughter]
hi i'm dick tiff um here actually
there's a lot of good memes in these
on the subreddit
really good stuff here let's take a look
well this yeah flakka not even once
addicts before and after alcohol weed
weed
yeah i don't know
say what
he was on something before this is the
before
and then flak is the worst one yeah the
flakka really hit you hard baby yeah amy
you don't like this photo of you like
you really don't like it the worst photo
i've ever seen of me in my life we're
gonna discuss that later more on that
later
there was a little bit of inner office
uh drama over this photo yep
yeah speaking of which we're gonna be
doing a hr segment there's been a lot of
drama a lot of conflict brewing behind
the scenes
so i will be sitting in as hr to mediate
the issues between the crews having
and hope we can find some good
resolution so that's coming up in a
little bit i hope so
yeah me too me too um maybe
after a full hour of yakking and
drinking milk yet again
this is the photo you don't like right
amy yeah i even know my eyes could go in
separate directions like that it was
it doesn't look like you're one of my
eyes looks a little off does it
yeah but i guess i see it i didn't
realize i kind of get pulled to my buck
teeth there actually it's kind of i'm
not sure if i should look at the eye
going the wrong direction or my teeth
but you don't have buck teeth
i questioned it now i don't know
i think it's funny how you see yourself
and you see this cataclysmic picture i
don't think anyone even like
it's just funny it's just a photo yeah
it's just a funny picture of you it's
not like
you know you're not it doesn't change
how you look right
that photo made me realize that you're
[ __ ] ugly as [ __ ] you know when i
left
when i look in the mirror i see this
photo now oh wow it scarred him
man
ethan calling zach the penguin while he
actually looks like him and uncle fester
costume okay that's fair enough zach
what do you think about that
um i'm gonna take it up with hr later
that's true and by the way i would
happily take on the role of penguin like
i mean i consider that a high honor
certainly got the physique
this is uncanny abs favorite photo again
i do see the resemblance
monday versus friday it's all a b
[Laughter]
do you see it
ian from the latest episode that's very
good
was it hard for you to switch with your
head down hand or was that all just
muscle memory
it's it's fine i know where all the
buttons are yeah
impressive though nonetheless cameron
really got hit i love this cat yeah that
was good
i'm really good
and then of course ian got hit with the
same meme
[Laughter]
sheesh
it's not that bad lena
unfazed the queen of the chip challenge
that's not bad i was trying to had um a
cute kitty like cam and ian's but that
works too
i mean you didn't you never even
expressed enough pain yeah we have
another chip lena if you're wanting to
ever prove your medal again maybe next
time maybe if somebody beats mine then
i'll go oh
that's a fallout interesting i love that
interesting i love that
before and after uh let's see yeah
yeah zach basically no reaction
that's
that's basically fine i would i
rewatched yesterday's episode and then i
was checking in on zach during my
suffering time the whole time i was like
zack you okay
i know that's what that's why i was
laughing about it at the time because
you ate the whole damn chip and
everyone's concerned about zach
people think i'm being such a f okay i
didn't eat the chip my throat started to
close up yeah so that is concerning at
that time so i'm glad you're doing okay
now
jesus [ __ ] christ
you know i get it no no i get it no it's
concerning
you didn't you but you your throat
didn't close right i thought it was i
couldn't breathe for a second right
right
right
yeah but you but it didn't right no i
don't know okay
but no we were all worried about you ian
disappeared
lena unfazed
in the scorpion chair
wow this is interesting what do you
think about this ian weeping woman
rembrandt it's powerful he's a work of
art
thank you
and then
okay this peter pettigrew this one
you're not gonna like maybe
no it's like the troll but the
resemblance is actually like super
super awful thank you
as a harry potter fan i'm doubly
offended he's a rat right
he could transform into it right yes
okay thank you
i see it though
he's the yasified version he's the
handsome one
all right thank you kim
rat do you see it
this is the meme zack saying they don't
even know i dipped my toes
[Laughter]
baby looking like he's about to take off
frieza
you know when i rewatched the episode i
realized i said contemplated instead of
contemplated
okay
i mean yeah i agree man if you want to
cast me in the penguin i'm here for it
you know what i mean i fully accept the
role i mean uh batman is available
usually dude [ __ ] love to play
penguin in that [ __ ] oh
didn't they they had um
colin farrell played penguin yeah but he
didn't really take on the role he was
just a gangster with his nickname was
penguin i want to be danny devito in the
sewer [ __ ] umbrella gun penguin you
know what i mean
that's what's up yeah
thank you
thoratic pains are definitely a penguin
branded
penguin brain oh brain yes
uh yes yes yes pepto-bismol now with
ave's face on it
there you have it this this this was
good too ab this they said
this is what you look like after the
chip
i think you've been taxidermied
is that what that is a taxidermy fox
yeah why why would they desecrate this
animal like that
i don't i don't know [ __ ] what did they
do to this poor creature
further animals right
anyway that's it so it's a really fun
episode i i had a lot of fun i'm glad uh
seems like everyone enjoyed it
i saw this video and i'm just saying
yeah it could have been a lot worse this
just showed up on one of our
feeds check this out
yep
yeah she went to the hospital
oh [ __ ]
i got a tweet right before the show
yesterday i have another girl who ended
up in the hospital as well she tagged
all of us
yeah i do i want to i saw some people
doing it there was a dude who did on the
subreddit great video but
don't do this especially if you're not
good or experienced with spicy it's it's
really really bad
yeah i'm just surprised that you can buy
that on amazon it just seems incredibly
dangerous
yeah in my opinion do not do this do not
do that at home
what's up tater tots we love you come on
over to the channel i'll be your daddy
i'll teach you guys everything top g
no uh
can we explain what you're doing for
people at home
yeah i'm just talking a tick tock life
he is because it's full of tater tots
[ __ ] yes this is my outreach program
tater tots come join listen i know hl3
but let's talk suck a little bit of dick
let's just suck a little bit of dick
so okay
um
now at this moment i would like to
commemorate 9 11 also that happened
uh was that that was when was not uh
sunday
yeah we never get we never observed yeah
we should have been on monday yeah yeah
i mean 9 11 it happened we didn't i
haven't forgotten have you guys
you know i
had forgotten but thankfully people made
posts on social media reminding me to
never forget and that reminded me and
now but you're already back bro you
already violated it by forgetting it it
doesn't matter if you have never made
the declaration personally to never
forget but i'm glad that other people
have not forgotten
on my behalf so that they can then
remind me so that i can go back to
remembering
that tragic day well
basically this is my favorite call to
remembering 911 which dan forgot being a
horrible american i could never forget
where i was on that day that's right
of course it comes from none other this
is a song the true patriot himself
liver king
who's at the 911 memorial uh
ground zero museum in new york which by
the way is a beautiful
a beautiful piece of art i don't know if
you guys have been there it's really a
powerful beautiful place i have not
oh you haven't been there it's really no
it is good is that maybe why i forgot
yeah oh yeah
yeah you guys should check it out if
you're in new york but
or if you're vr they have it in vr and
it's wild
say what yeah there's a 911 memorial in
vr yeah you went
i i checked it out yes oh maybe we
should go to uh when we do that
you could like look up and see that
seems like a horrible idea what do you
mean should we visit them
absolutely we should it was like an
interactive
documentary the thing i was watching but
actually in the metaverse there was a
911 memorial some guy was pretending to
um
pleasure himself next to it was really
[ __ ] up yeah i'm sure nothing bad will
happen of that yeah 911 never happened
in the metaverse that's all i know
can we yeah can we do can we reenact
that i mean there's probably plane
simulator games out there you want to
laugh at it
let's do that let's visit 911 memorial
tomorrow
all right
it's actually right next to the queen's
memorial i'm not even kidding oh hell
yeah
i got the double header burns
double respect yep
two of the most tragic things ever to
ever happen to me
well hold on the 911 is tragic the queen
dying i mean god [ __ ] i mean you know
rest in peace the good always die young
but
9 11 serious business this is britain's
this is britain's 9 11.
all right so here's
and by the way but the point i'm trying
to make is
when you go to this
memorial
it's very serious it's very somber
it seems to me like it would be a good
place time and place to wear a shirt is
all
nope i mean you might as well go to like
the holocaust museum shirtless i mean
you know sweatpants
that's the way to go just a little bit
more formal i'm just a shirt
you know
but anyway here's the liver king
this is a solemn place
an american place the ultimate subprimal
act was committed right here
yes so
also he can he refers to the
911 terrorists as a subprimal act loved
that which which is funny because he
always says stuff is subprimal so i
think eating
broccoli he holds in the same reverence
the same contempt as hijacking a plane
well it's in the same category but he
does specify that this is the ultimate
subprimal act so that there clearly must
be degrees of subprimalness if this on
the scale of subprimal you have eating
broccoli and and then crashing your
plate
into a building these are the extreme
ends
i don't get that i mean sub primals
don't
okay i just the whole
venn diagram of some private primal is
just
right now we stand as a family we're
gonna honor a moment of silence for
those that went before us
god it must be so embarrassing to be
this guy to be your dad i mean he's like
a sideshow dude like in new york city
he's one of these guys
that you see in like american
flag speedo like one of these characters
i mean the man is a sideshow pizza he's
at the 911 memorial shirtless and
[ __ ] great show paying his respects
what is happening he gave us a gp out
the river king out
liver king out peace out yeah but it did
remind me i was like oh [ __ ] you're
right dana
you know
it's 9 11.
this man has ab implants i've heard
how
[ __ ] dare
you i know i'm sorry what the [ __ ] what
a sub primal statement yeah i know i'm
sorry
i mean
that's right i hope the tater tots heard
that yeah take a shower tater tots what
do you guys think oh let me see tater
tots on tick tock you guys think
well he says he's natural okay yeah i
mean
clearly [ __ ] yes tater tots
do you guys think that uh
liver king is natural so yeah i try to
include them in the conversation i'm the
one getting plowed
yeah okay well shout out liver king um
more like fatty
liver fatty liver king his liver is
probably close to [ __ ] failure with
his diet
we're trying to get this guy on the show
nah it's not happening bro he's
subprimal
whoa wow he's sub primal
sorry
is anybody
what are you doing
i don't want him on the show anymore he
turned into like a weird grifter for
like supplements and [ __ ]
i mean he's like alex he's like yo check
out my [ __ ] beast liver mix i put it
in rat poison asbestos and ground up
liver heart it clearly works i mean look
at the man
king
also
i don't know if you guys knew this but
it was a
a solemn day in 2014 paris hilton
sex tape dropped a night in paris
and we just realized this from this post
did you guys know that that that the
paris hilton porn tape
started with a
911 memorial
this is i swear to god this is real
yes app check this
i owe olivia a public apology she's the
one that let me know about this thank
you brought it up the other day and i
straight up was like you got trolled
that's not real that's somebody memeing
on twitter no looked it up she was 100
right it opens with the
911 memorial yep and people were just
like yes
yeah nobody even talked about it until
like the 911 fog kind of settled
they're like absolutely we were insane
back then paris hilton dropped their
porn tape with in memory of 911 we will
never forget what are you talking about
remember the fallen before you bust one
out is what they were saying obviously
holy [ __ ] dude
you gonna do it i don't think you could
i don't think you could debut anything
without being like in the memory of 911
for like five years afterwards yeah no
that was even a porn
it was an insane time in this country
a couple years after uh 9 11. i think
more people remember that sex tape than
9 11 at this point
never forget ah
yeah night
[Music]
we love it folks
shout out to paris hilton
a true patriot
okay after this we have a special uh
presentation
we recently celebrated a couple of
anniversaries
abe and lena came
came to california oh she's gone
i guess i can wait for her to come back
yeah it's lena
she's working yeah i know
well we can wait but yeah when she comes
back we
they came to us with nothing
with nothing but the shirts on their
back from detroit that's right they came
with knives
his clothing and tatters
his car barely running he was a mess he
was subprimal yeah
he was so so primal he was close to
flying an airplane into a building
but i swooped down
and i said lena and a.b
you guys are better than this i see your
true potential i ethan cline
your lord and savior the most gracious
human being alive
i dip down into the bowels of detroit
worst city in the maybe the world well
in the world probably huh no
terrible city
i took the knife out of abe's side
i shook the dirt out of lena's hair
kissed his old nasty and i said come
here come come to the golden side where
the grass is greener
and that was uh
three two years two years ago two years
ago and they haven't looked back and
they just they stank me every time i see
them and
they're just so grateful for me you're
making a joke but you really did
it was a time in my life where i was
very afraid i felt like a loser
and uh
you changed both of our lives you did
save our lives wait what were you afraid
of
the end what i was doing with my life i
mean my parents wanted me to do medicine
i was getting older i hated it i hated
what i was doing i hated my nine to five
and whenever i had time i'd make youtube
videos
and uh what are you afraid of it wasn't
going anywhere but
you saved me
god bless you you're like you're like my
jack dawson i know man someone saved me
uh lena i was just talking about how i
saved your life if you want to add
anything to that she can't
yeah
yeah who saved my life yeah it was me
two years ago
that's right yeah thank you you did
i can agree yep what was your day job
baby uh i was at my uncle's medical
office
sort of running like the day-to-day
things nine to five that's interesting
[ __ ] hated it how was the pay
bad
yeah
it was bad and then lena what was your
day job two years ago
i managed chiropractic clinics oh you
were in the back the enemy's den i think
we talked about that yes
yes so you know two years ago today i
said come let me save you my children
actually not with
dropping the schtick
these two guys are some of the greatest
employees you could ever wish for
they're both super smart hard working
taking the initiative
i feel so lucky and honored that they're
both here working uh with us it's like
uh
you couldn't ask for better people
and so i say [ __ ] you to your uncle's
medical place and i say [ __ ] you to your
uncle's chiropractor uh whatever [ __ ]
you i say
you should have paid them more you blew
it now they come out now they're over
here
i mean
honestly we would have moved for any
like big youtube channel just because
we've always want to be involved but to
be what but to be hired by our favorites
what the [ __ ] to be hired by our
favorite channel is more than we could
have ever why would you say that you
ruined this moment i'm not ruining it
i'm saying it was a dream come true
it was something i couldn't even imagine
lena do you back do you support what do
you think you come for any youtube
channel i don't know because i never had
the idea in mind that we would even move
out here to work for a youtube channel
but just the fact that that first offer
and it was our favorite youtubers was
just amazing
maybe linus tech she's looking for a new
computer guy maybe
no i'm just kidding i love you guys i'm
glad you're here enough with the shtick
we have we have gifts for you guys let's
start with uh who are we starting with
lena's lena
wonderful lena
we trust her she's she's she spends time
with our kids we're blindfolded and then
open your mouth and just uh chew and uh
it's another it's just another chip yeah
i'm so excited
lina we trust her with our children i
mean the kids love her she is the most
trustworthy the sweetest the kindest the
hard-working person
[Music]
thanks so much i love you guys too
so thank you and with so
the utmost appreciation
we present to lena
keep the blindfold on
it's coming out bye
no peeking did you know about this maybe
yes
do you know about yours no okay
[Music]
okay
okay lena are we ready
wow
can i open my eyes wait not yet not yet
just not yet a little bit a little bit
yeah
that's good
okay you guys ready
lina you can take off your blindfold now
[Music]
we honor lena with her very own
background i'm so happy
yeah of course cam got his own
background recently and lena
oh my gosh thank you guys so much and
sam this is a work of art thank you so
much i am honored i love this so much
thank you guys
oh my god well it's our pleasure
thank you
it's the least we could do for christ's
sake
maybe we can we need to extra can you
show lena there's a bit of a like shadow
behind her i wonder if we could get an
extra light there to
blow out the shadow it's not urgent just
a note
so there you have it lena wow what a
what a treat what a treasure
and moving on to dear
dear
evie
[Music]
where will we be without a bee
thank you guys he'd work for any
youtuber but luckily it's not what i
meant it was me maybe hopefully by four
years you'll understand me
but luckily it was me
two years of abe he's a great guy a hard
worker one of the greatest
a treasure a treat a legend
go ahead and open your uh
your present there
[Music]
oh
oh it's two things okay hold on first
thing
it is a bulls jersey
this is starkiller
thank you guys michael jordan's number
right yes i'm a huge
no no it's not my so okay i know nothing
about sports and for some reason i
didn't compute that what makes it a
jordan jersey is his number okay not the
fact that it's
bulls but the number is he there's more
players on the board well i i yes right
not just one
that is true i did do some research
though and i found that
on abey's channel the first video
i saw it was in 2018.
so there is a significance to it okay so
that's why i picked that number is there
a bulls 18 who has the number 18 on the
bulls uh i don't know me no i don't know
evidently there wasn't at the time so
it's not like some other random well
there you have it um
thank you
very interesting
but yeah amy's a huge michael jordan fan
apparently you've watched the
documentary like 20 times it wasn't for
the documentary i never got the job 20
times i was what yeah
is that right how do you figure
because
i was watching it the night before i
sent you what ultimately got me hired
and i remember telling lena at like 4am
that
man i feel like i really should have
sent ethan that
and i was thinking i was just motivated
because that documentary and i did it
the next day at work and then you
offered me the job so wait wait you you
sent me what
i sent you some research that you were
oh
okay okay
just like jordan man just just like
jordan this is you bison della
he was number 18 on the bulls in 1997.
that's your guy
this is very cool
my first youtube video was 2015 but
those are privated but this is this is
where it really began this is when i
made the video defending ethan that got
me the job so it does have significance
well what i saw was 2018 no 18 makes
sense that's when i made the video
defining ethan and also in your favorite
player bison yeah bison you missed 100
of the shots you don't take isn't that
right uh
was that michael jordan great that
everyone lincoln that was michael
he might still scott michael scott yeah
was that michael scott or abraham
lincoln
it was both at the same time actually
and then there's one more gift in there
for you baby so it's it's the last dance
on the front and on the back
it's twilight oh whoa that's double
header i mean
this is you will never find a shirt like
right
those two interests coming together i
love it thank you guys this may be the
rarest shirt of all time so
that's definitely yeah i love it thank
you sam thank you everyone so just let
the world know you know
there it is a b and lena
thank you guys
such a pleasure thank you guys i'm glad
you're here into another
not just 20 or not that's two 20 years
together wow
yes
of course assuming that like another
bigger youtuber doesn't offer you a job
not what i meant casey neistat just
moved back to new york bro your
apartment's in manhattan or you've been
scouting that not even for casey he's
like yo he's like yo abby i need you to
boost the board around with me all day
and film me
[Music]
well then maybe make sick vlogs together
bro i want to make sick vlogs and
boosted board with you all so life new
york living dog i want you to come
jogging with me every morning
you got me the casey shout out from my
one year so that was really cool
yeah you're welcome
thank you thank you i can move mountains
for you buddy i appreciate it
and thank you to all the fans as well
who have changed both our lives we
appreciate it all right
okay so
that's fun
um i really have to pee i don't know why
it's like
i started slamming these fiber
supplement in the morning but it's like
a lot of liquid and fiber supplement so
you have to pee out of your [ __ ] no
no no it's just a lot of clearing right
now
maybe it's the game steps going through
you
maybe we have to do our ad maybe
i don't know either let's do that first
and then you can go pee or vice versa
okay let me just go p real fast okay um
while i go p just to keep the show
running
um
you guys can show the new jimmy lee meme
and the pokey mentioning love on stream
if someone wants to take the reins on
that sure
the new jimmy lee meme
yeah it's an old-timey joke it's an
old-timey joke where we threatened to uh
to kill
crew members of the h3 podcast
it was you maybe right that he yeah
yeah he's like kill starkiller
yeah
[Music]
uh so ian died peacefully
at balmoral this afternoon anyways who
cares merch in the bio and his head is
long
and pixelated i'm like [ __ ] this pony
conehead stinks you suck
he's gonna text zach and i immediately
as soon as that goes through well funny
enough he he texts me like two minutes
ago
sending me the meme
oh actually he sent it to me he sent it
to me i told him i told him he's all
this is funny i'm like no too far
yeah i guess he's not saying that he's
gonna kill you and he's just saying that
ian is
is dead oh he sent me one where a b is
killing him actually
i mean now people are gonna think it's
me people get to think this is me morals
a pretty high honor right
somebody just donated said
bison uh dell is adele or delhi bison
dell was murdered at sea i know i'm
reading about all costs i'm reading
about that on wikipedia it's crazy what
the [ __ ]
well stay off
stay off the boats ab yeah the guy with
18 has his number yeah he was murdered
at sea oh my god i know i told leona in
2018 if i don't get to 100k by 2019 i'm
gonna quit youtube and i pretty much did
and ethan found the video years later so
don't give up kids
don't give up
and don't get on a boat anytime soon
yeah stay off stay off the boats land
bound stay off of boats i'll stay in
them sam did you sew two shirts together
i did i thought you did
so the two fronts are two backs it's two
fronts interesting and uh they're both
the same size
but one of them is like definitely a
little smaller than the other one so i
had to uh
i made it work made it work i like the
twilight movie did you guys enjoy this
jimmy lee meme
i i posted i said this meme stinks you
suck
ha ha
got him [ __ ] rocked ian died
peacefully at belmoral this afternoon
like the queen anyway who cares
merchant bio savage bro
jimmy are you reading this stuff
do you see the one he just sent me i
dropped it in our
discord let's see
dude
this doesn't have a personal info does
it no
a b is going after the jersey outlaw
there's no camel jimmy wait what the
[ __ ] am i looking at
give this to a b
we're just having a good time wait wait
wait wait wait wait a b is going after
the can you zoom in on that
this was an edit cam and not this edit
but initially there was a cam edit of me
driving yeah when we went to the moon
together yes
that's insanely good the back of you and
then the bongo and the rear view i mean
like whoever's making these is [ __ ]
awesome the love and the dashboard there
too dude this whoever's doing this
should make memes for us like i want to
post these to our socials
yeah reach out
you guys gotta start posting memes on
the sub again it's a lot of known memes
i've been looking for memes to post
you know just putting that out there
this content is so freaking good stop
your what your talents are wasted on
jimmy come to us yeah this would kill on
on our network
there it is uh ivan martinez just
donated 20 and said i want to get a
portrait tat of ethan what pick though
i have one of mine my gamer stop
spilling on me uh i don't know
don't get my face on
no need for all that i don't know
um
okay so did you guys show the pokey
thing uh no we hadn't gotten to that
working through the top of the show
love you're gonna love this
yes sir uh our friend of the show
wonderful uh pokeman or pokemon
what is this photo
which one
that you have framed so nicely in this
very beautiful back background which one
of of this random person is that [ __ ]
thank you you think that's me
she thought it was i don't know it could
be like you think this is me i thought
it was you with makeup on like
oh it's like a mustache yeah yeah
his name is love isn't that a cool name
love yeah no
it's louvre someone didn't watch the h3
podcast so if you want to know the
context you're gonna have to watch what
the heck in dog
real ones only wokey yeah
she is she is we gotta have her back on
such good vibes
such a w real fun up and congratulations
i'm not a random guy
that's right hell yeah brother hell no
she got a picture of you in her back
round dude yeah yeah it's super cool i'm
actually i actually
yeah every time i watch her stream now
i i see it in the back there and i'm
sorry
stop
that is just inappropriate yeah don't
joke we're good friends she's a friend
of the show we're good friends
yeah i don't think dan was serious i
think he's just joking i know but like
we can't joke like that dan don't ever
joke on comedic podcast please i was
also joking roasting yeah
like like you know we have a we have a
woman come on and then we got a joke
that he that you know
i guess
he's having a big joke out of it
it's like
you said he's in
oh i thought you said he's hitting it no
oh come on oh that would that would be
that okay
that's what i thought i said you're in
bro
come on that's just too much dan
you're just inappropriate
absolutely gross she gets way too much
attention like that she doesn't need
that from you dan
l-o-l
yeah but anyway
um
moving on this friday we have a special
guest you guys are not going to believe
this so what's the biggest one you've
ever you guys will not believe this i
saw this clip
okay let's do this we're supposed to do
our ad oh [ __ ] yeah let me do that then
okay i have a huge announcement about
howie mandel you guys gonna love this
but let me just thank our two sponsors
today we love so well starting with
honey
let's freaking go
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easiest way to save when you're
shopping on your iphone or your computer
we all shop online
ela is a serial shopper that woman
cannot stop spending
money you know what they say
but about women
women be shopping women
baby what's the origin of that i don't
even know it's very funny women be
shopping you hear that tater tots
watching on tick tock women be shopping
am i right
yeah she'd be shopping but
she also be saving that's right
uh honey is just a miracle you install
it it runs seamlessly in the background
as soon as you get to the checkout
it automatically looks for the best
coupon code on the internet and applies
it it's like no catch
no brainer just free money man uh thanks
to
thanks to honey
manual searching for coupon codes is a
thing in the past honey's the free
shopping tool i already said that
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites and when you check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupon
boom bada bing it searches it finds it
automatically applies you watch the
price drop
magically we've got it from
shoe store check this out this came from
a fupa trooper just the other day they
emailed it to me oh that's nice freaking
shoes for cruise anybody who's worked in
a restaurant probably remembers this
company
save 10 bucks off the workshop that's
what i'm saying let's go sit so easy
it's like free and we've got it on like
postmates we've got it on like furniture
electronics it works
all over the internet man honey doesn't
just work on desktop now it also works
on your iphone too just activate it on
safari
on your phone and save on the go if you
don't already have honey you're going to
be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show which we
love thank you so much i use honey and i
love honey get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
h3 that's
h3 thank you thank you for peace and
love
women be shopping as a catchphrase from
the 1996 film the nutty professor
said by comedian dave chappelle as an
insult comic oh reggie what
that seems like such a modern idiom
women be shopping
hold on can you pull up a clip of that i
i know i don't want to risk copyright
if it's just fast enough and small
enough i gotta see you know he's got
like the the weird hair going on you
know
women be shopping
and then eddie murphy kicks his ass in
like a comedic way
i guess it's meant to be not funny then
but now i mean it's very funny it's well
it's funny because it's so dumb and
ironic yeah
kevin also says it in the office at one
point oh really yeah
okay well because it fits perfectly into
that post-ironic meme meaning yeah it's
wow
damn dave chappelle
women be shopping ladies and gentlemen
also uh quickly a thank you to
our final sponsor here today stamps.com
if you're a small business owner
you know how important it is to be ready
for the insane holiday season and it's
sneaking right up on us
if you haven't started preparing for the
chaos of holiday mailing and shipping
you're already falling behind luckily
stamps.com has everything you need to
make your life a whole lot easier it's
24 7 post office that you can access
from anywhere no lines no traffic no
hassle
stamps.com is insanely good if you are
using the mail
in any capacity you need to be using
stamps.com because
dan's uh girlfriend ally uses it we talk
about it all the time
they send you a scale
you weigh the package of the envelope a
big package whatever it is
you automatically print the postage
which is heavily discounted by the way
through stamps.com i'm talking i'm
talking up to 86 off ups
and usps discounts too
you you
weigh it
print the postage boom and then they're
gonna come get it from your house dude
or you just put it in your mailbox it's
like unbelievable
the future is here it's cheaper
it's more convenient it's here and you
don't even have to think about it that's
right
we're no we don't we don't ride ponies
anymore like paul revere okay we got the
future now
the pony days are over
pony express anyone you remember that
[ __ ] from yeah that wasn't paul revere
no i know but he rode a horse
full size what they call pony express
though
they that's a totally different thing
that i know that was like yeah i know a
pony but they didn't write ponies anyway
nobody's doing long distance trips on
ponies are they pony express
you know a pony is like uh
hey i'm just having a little trot the
pony express was an american express
mail service that used relays of horse
mounted riders yeah
why they call it the horse express
so like american express credit card
it was the pony express it was very
important by the way learned all about
an ap history yeah american history
predates the the american uh post office
shout out pony express
yeah but stamps.com is way cooler than
that [ __ ]
uh for more than 20 years stamps.com has
been indispensable for over a billion a
million a billion no a million
businesses
get access to the usps and ups services
right
from your home
with inflation every dollar counts you
need these discounts
major discounts off usps and 86 off ups
boom boom boom it's insane it's
wonderful guys and we have a great
promotion for you here today get ahead
of the holiday chaos this year get
started with stamps.com today sign up
with promo code h3 for a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a free digital skill
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter the code h3 thank you thank
you to stamps yes baby
yes we love stamps
yes we love stamps
shout out to all the tater tots who are
they're seven dude this is awesome
there's
people just watching literally to throw
tomatoes and type l but that that's so
guys just come watch you guys are gonna
have so much fun it was a long recess
are they back in class by now
no they're not on recess they're here to
learn just i'm telling you i can be your
mentor i can be your alpha male
you
hero i can know your alpha male come on
man i'll teach you how to get laid
that doesn't involve uh gbs or whatever
that drug is called
gdh
ghb ghb one of those
yeah
okay come on
idra
idra elvis just donated fifty dollars
oh thanks adrian andrew elvis i'm
rooting for you buddy
get that james bond roll one day
skye bevins thank you so much for the
gifted appreciate you brother
today's mine and husband's third wedding
anniversary bottom teddy fresh gear
thank you s said
legendary
i said idra elvis
thank you queen
all right so back to howie now
i have a long long storied history with
howie mandel we went on his podcast now
how long ago was that like a month ago
or a long story history of
60 days
how he does stuff
yeah and
yeah it was about two months ago we just
blew up that show man we cracked
the records
we still got to be number one right i
mean yeah we put this podcast on the map
i'm just going to say it
look at this we destroyed bill maher
bill maher you're bro bill maher
has literally no chance and then jeff
dunham we put bobby lee i mean he's
funny but come on he's not he's not me
put this podcast on the map
and how he's been internally in my debt
we're homies we text all the time
obviously you guys know the prolapse
thing happened and
i've been trying to get to the bottom of
this for a long time
so after this clip
i texted my boy and i said come on the
show howie we need to do this there's
enough lore
and howie being the absolute legend he
is
he said
this was yesterday i think or monday
yeah
and he said i'll come
this week he's coming on friday this man
it's happening
this is a busy man
this is howie mandel america's uncle or
that i don't know he's he's got a lot on
america's um
family friend yeah yeah
exactly uh he does the damn
oh agt
he's a busy guy
so he had simon cal on the show
um
how did that one view how were the views
on that one i want to see a few people
care about simon
i don't want to uh i don't want to
say anything oh bro nobody cares about
you simon eleven thousand views in one
day what a [ __ ] loser bro
i didn't want to say it but holy [ __ ]
nobody cares about you bro
damn the pick they used of him in the
thumbnail is uh
that one in the middle
it's the most
i don't want to disparage his guests
this i'll wait till afterwards but yeah
[ __ ]
i don't like simon cowell but
we don't have to talk about that
together
but um
yeah i put this [ __ ] on the map so
oh
i mean yeah so this is the picture they
used to simon cowell and in fact that
was the best picture they could find
he literally looks like a [ __ ]
resuscitated cadaver for an open casket
funeral like
they put the makeup on him they had to
like
use tape and some kind of [ __ ] to keep
his eyes open
you know
like this he his body is being held
together by tape and [ __ ]
twigs
oh my god
it looks like each hair on his beard was
surgically installed
you started this sentence let me remind
you of i don't want to disparage his
guess before it comes off but you pulled
it up
i thought i would just let the picture
speak for itself i i shouldn't say it
i'm going to say something i don't i i
probably shouldn't say he's just such a
dick
but okay whatever we love uh
i think i saw this clip and it was sent
in our work chat ethan
said he had to close the video because
he was so disgusting
i don't know what but first of all i
just i really dislike the guy
[Laughter]
i've heard really bad things about him
also one of the things he did is
apparently he [ __ ] his best friends
bro we're ruining our chance of howie
coming on right what how he's coming on
friday isn't simon cowell's boss if
someone's not gonna see this uh
i was thinking the same thing dan
okay let me say something nice about
simon
i love his ass on the game shows he's
great he's entertaining
okay you know i agree with that
uh but he yeah he [ __ ] his best
friend's wife and
[Music]
yeah uh what are we going to do about it
how we uh what do we do about it how he
asks
is this the result of coving
if so what are we going to do about
simon cowell of course would be a
billion dollars
uh they they of course simon cowell said
hook me up and the dentist said uh do
you like piano keys or
and he said hook me up fam
somebody you know is this covid related
yeah
um
thank you by the way to flood waves
don't tell elon but you guys make my 60
hour work week at tesla so much better
yo i don't know that's a lot of hours
yeah don't tell elon you're listening to
us man yeah
dude
he'll
you'll have a workplace accident real
fast you know what i mean
those machines are dangerous your hand
might just get caught in one of them
all right well anyway here's the clip
howie
uh
that you know i love howie mendel so
what's the biggest one you've ever done
um
i think on youtube yeah ethan klein
and uh you're giving the same look i
didn't know ethan before i had watched
his he's got probably the number one
podcast in the world and it's called h3
the eighth grade
and it's kind of
it's him and his wife and a bunch of
friends and it's very controversial is
this controversial and i would that's
what i wanted to talk to him i mean more
or less controversial than posting a
prolapsed anus
probably more
yeah okay i accept that
why is he got this like dear leader
simon cowell this reminds me of like
yeah it's like kim jong-un vibes the
picture
did you know simon cal hit a hole in one
on every course on this golf course
you know simon cowell doesn't [ __ ] or
piss
it's incredible he has no sphincter he
has no [ __ ] our dear leader that's
how that's how he sees simon he's his
dear leader
anyway here we go the h3 podcast and
it's kind of um
it's him and his wife and a bunch of
friends and it's very controversial is
this controversial and i will that's
what i wanted to talk to him about that
because i like you
do not want to get canceled
i just realized this is the first
episode we've done since this interview
with simon cowell happened right yeah so
what if simon's watching right now
she's looking for new talent on howie's
recommendation and then all that
just slamming him maybe you need a new
judge for agt i'm controversial i got
chops
nah he's not watching please don't send
this to simon cowell oh i really want to
talk to howie on friday
how he's coming dude how we me and how
we are dogs you don't understand we're
like tight
i gotta tell you i'm very sad because
i guess we can announce this here today
too friday
will be the first episode of the h3
podcast that i will not be here for i'm
taking the day off go to a wedding
i tried to tell dan do not take a day
off
that that is just like you need
if you're not dedicated bro you're gonna
take a friday off you've got to show
dedication
i mean i cannot wait to drop the ball on
that you guys no you guys are gonna be
fine you're not gonna be fine but i am
very sad because i think it's gonna be a
legendary episode there's another guest
coming on friday can i announce this
sure that's cool yeah
we finally
finally got a hold of c-man
and he's going to be calling in on the
same day
crossover
do we have any game we got to plan some
fun stuff for c-man some foot stuff
maybe we can get just how we have a wiki
feed
i don't know
because i mean that's basically writes
itself doesn't it is there something off
about this simon cow picture
no
howie's got a
one eight out of five and and is there a
good show there's only four photos i
don't know how pretty good are okay i
don't know they're okay i wanna so we're
gonna have c-man rank howie's feet
oh how he's gonna hate this
it's like paparazzi shots
he's he's in good shape yeah he looks
pretty good out there yeah oh my god
c-man is gonna eat his heart out here
man with the painted toes i think he
said he doesn't like painted toes if i
recall he likes natural because i
zach's toes were painted or something
and and he was like ah it's okay you
know they're okay i don't know they're
all right
yeah so i'm super excited you guys it's
gonna be so fun people think it's gonna
be a disaster without dan no you guys me
and howie are dogs you guys don't
understand we are
tight
he's coming on i gave him the i gave him
the call and he said i'll be there
friday okay that is incredible he's the
man with no dad how long until a
prolapse accidentally appears on stream
well that's up to you ian you're the
switcher that's true you tell me we'll
see you are the gatekeeper
yeah it's gonna be fun though so that's
a lot to look forward to shout out simon
cowell
who is uh basically
like gazing into the eye of sauron
like yeah there are bad pictures of
simon cowell but that clip on howie like
he looked perfectly normal on that one
[Laughter]
that's outrageous
when i see it oh my god bro
did somebody this man is wearing someone
else's skin
this is the [ __ ] dude for men in
black the roach
why is he wearing someone else's skin so
crazy looking holy [ __ ] what the skin is
draped off him i've never seen skin
drape
why does it look like that buffalo cow
what
how old is simon like he better be 90 or
some [ __ ] to be looking like this and
then i'll be like he looks good for his
age no he's probably in his 50s or 62
that's what but my thing is the plastic
surgery never works
this man
it's not that it never works it's just
it's very noticeable when it doesn't
but this guy is rich as hell he can
afford the best of the best ryan kavkav
my my thing is dripping
is this my fault or the cubs there's
water in the crack
oh
where is screws yeah
how the hell were you able to diagnose
that from sweden just like that bro
i know it's just that was incredible two
lead
like a day yeah yeah i'm a
veteran
dude i love the tick tock lifestyle
people are literally just watching the
spam l3 l3 you guys are my heroes
join us on youtube you guys are gonna
have so much fun
that's the game
i'll teach you things tate never could
like how to uh
find the clitoris i don't know right
i'm a man of god
instagram chess says you look like you
lost weight you look good ethan
thank you guys
you know i've been trying what a
contrast between instagram and people
okay
you know i've been trying really hard
i'm thank you guys for saying that i
haven't been talking about it a lot but
i've been good i've been hitting the
treadmill
i've been um
really doing good on my dieting
controlling my eating
i've been doing good so thank you guys
thank you
what is going on here simon
it's like they didn't do a skin lift
it's like they did a skin add like they
added extra skin
they got they get they got the procedure
wrong they layer it up
what the [ __ ]
he's only 62.
it looks like you know and face-off when
they put on another dude's face
face off he's put on another man's face
who do you think he swapped with
ted bundy oh no
sorry all right let's move on
uh ted bundy's face is not available
simon cowell i'm done with botox i
looked like a horror film bro
actually you know what i think he looks
fine here like he looks normal like he
looks like a normal person yeah
i should think he looks good here
so i love that
oh howie oh no howie we love you don't
howie you're the man
nothing
yeah he looks good in these photos
i think he looks fine well on the right
is ten years ago it's no wait it says 20
21. yeah oh one year dude oh wait that's
a one year look he looks good in both of
them he looks like a normal person here
here it's like a nice photo they
airbrush and stuff and touch it up and
stuff but he looks good in both of them
doesn't look like he's
melting yeah
um wow dude this is a comprehensive page
holy [ __ ] okay simon cowell through the
years wow shout out tmz wow what the
hell
let's take a look let's take this
journey together
beautiful natural face here right what
year is this
it's like when american idol started so
early two thousand yeah early i think
you can do simon through the years and
not put the year of the photo
[Music]
but he looks good looks great
this is a cautionary tale guys it's just
not worth it just you know don't get
older don't age
oh my god what happened between that
what happened between his
and this
[Music]
oh my god
this is where it goes all wrong
[Music]
something went
deeply wrong in that room operating room
oh my god
yeah oh [ __ ] you looked better man oh my
whoa what the [ __ ]
i don't know what else to say i'm not
i'm tripping i'm genuinely shocked when
i see this man's face
[ __ ]
oh god
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this
donut said look uh he looks like dwight
from the office wearing the cpr dolls
mask
totally
what happened to your eyelids oh
you you leaned eyelids bro
oh the zac efron plastic surgery is
another tragedy dude
some people thought maybe he was just
puffy but it's confirmed no it's
definitely he said that he he did break
his jaw um but
it certainly looks like he has films no
he got like cheek filler everything skin
filler he was one of the most beautiful
men and he just now he looks like he's
all cowled up well the thing is he did
an interview a few years ago where
people were like oh man the filler sucks
and then he got it dissolved and now
it's back again
so maybe it's a pattern when it
dissolves does he just look like normal
again yeah
oh dissolve that dude please
i think he i don't think you can
dissolve this whatever this is
i think the problem is they got here by
dissolving his skin
all right what could be worse than this
see now he looks fine
a little white on the teeth but
otherwise he looks good like a normal
person you know what i'm saying like you
meet this guy you're like this is a real
person
you see this [ __ ] my kids are gonna
[ __ ] cry this guy walks to my house
theodore is going to run
i'll be okay
you know this this he looks pretty good
pretty normal
yeah he looks great man look you can see
his pores that's normal people have
pores
simon
you need friend like me man to tell you
he looks good here
you need someone like me to tell you
you're beautiful the way you are bro
simon cow next guest let's ask howie if
he got to end with simon
no i'm cute
we could have asked
we could have before this is our bridge
they're literally on an america's got
talent press tour right now together
they are yes that's why that's why
they're doing promo okay well good how
he's gonna come promote agt number one
show in america
[Music]
well in a way he's promoting right now
just not in person true
mr cowell as well he looks great here
simon you just need a friend like me to
tell you speak the truth now it sounds
like a little sideways here but still
okay
beautiful man
dog face pony soldier
you don't want to be freaking handsome
what you don't want to be friends with
simon knowing what he does to friends
wives dude oh [ __ ]
i trust ela though but i don't even want
to know that he's trying you know i mean
why are you worried about my wife
best friend's wife got her pregnant dude
damn
um looks great
looks great
looks great frankly
so there you go they kind of did him
dirty by putting the most like golem
photos up front this man looks like he
had the ring for a thousand years
look at this [ __ ]
this one looks like this might have been
living in the [ __ ] trench with the
ring of power for a thousand years
[ __ ]
this guy had 30 degree burns and his
skin regrafted on his face
but anyway we love simon
maybe i'm be maybe i'm being too hard on
the guy
does have a beautiful hairline that's
right maddie can't take that away from
the man got a gorgeous hairline
for 62
yeah
i'm sure it's as real as his teeth
i'm growing my hair back people
golly
look at what they wrote here well if age
is a song
simon's now ready to face the music
oh he says he says of himself i probably
did have a little too much botox a
couple years ago because everyone on tv
has it now i have facials but nothing
too extravagant at the moment okay good
for good for you uh simon
simon's so rich though because he owns
the ip of all these
mega yeah x factor right gta
or
agt he was also a big exec at uh sony i
think he discovered the spice girls is
that right yeah uh el divo
well he was also a huge
uh
he oh these shows are in the uk too he
owns all those 600 million yeah this
guy's crushing yeah x factor started in
england
and then it came over here too
discovered one direction on that show
too so i mean fifth harmony do they get
a piece of the action
they like own one direction i think sony
them for a second yes sony cause he was
i think his or still was ahead at sony
and i think that's who they signed to
i'm sure he gets some piece of it some
way
yeah people are feeling bad for simon i
did go a little hard on him
sometimes i just you know because i
don't i just think he's a dick so
sometimes i just go a little bit hard
but ultimately you know it's on the
inside what counts right guys
and trust me on the inside he looks even
worse no i'm just kidding
but i do i do
want to encourage
people to not get plastic surgery
personally
i think that you know
you're addressing a
symptom
of a deeper issue
and it actually ends up making you look
worse it's kind of a crazy field like um
they make you weird looking it just
doesn't look natural and you pay a bunch
of money
look at this [ __ ] guy
beautiful face and then now he looks
like damn uh uh now he looks like david
hasselhoff he had some squidworth the
man that was in one uh
baywatch and then he wanted to be david
hasselhoff
but it's a strange cycle i think they
get one surgery feel good
think they're gonna get the same and
they keep going and they can't stop
i think sometimes plastic surgery can be
good
i have a lot of friends who feel
much better
you know what more expressive with
themselves that's true like i think when
i looked at people like
uh
what's the girl's name the model the
jenner caitlyn bella hadid no caitlyn
jenner oh caitlyn jenner her plastic
surgery was kind of crazy she totally
transformed herself are you talking
about kylie or kylie no no no okay uh
whatever yeah maybe maybe i'm speaking
in absolutes maybe they just they just
go too far with it
but it's a it's a it's a scary road to
go down
i think if you've got like a beast
monster nose like cutting that down
sometimes it's a good thing
for your self-confidence yeah it's
different it affects people's confidence
differently
it did sometimes it forces people to be
more critical about themselves and then
they continue to get work done sometimes
they fix something that they don't like
and then they feel great
yeah that's true some some are okay
maybe my problem is just with filler
maybe that's mine yeah i've never been a
fan of
i feel like some people's lip fillers
look awesome though
really i don't know
well maybe maybe that's it maybe but let
me back it all up
some people are saying i don't know what
i'm talking about let me back all of it
up
just rewind problem is fillers okay
thank you zach had an accident yeah i
know he did but he got filler
thank you
i think you can uh like both both your
and olivia's arguments can be true at
the same time we shouldn't like promote
people to get it and
yeah i don't know i think there's an in
between
w love love
all right thank you love exactly we're
in between
yeah i don't know we have no stance on
this issue uh
i'm backing out of it gracefully and
slowly i have to wait for a minute what
happened now people just getting mad at
me because i'm going toward a plastic
surgery oh no delete me from this
conversation
what's important is that you're
comfortable with yourself
that's all right
and that you don't end up looking like
handsome squidward someone i mean
they're i think the doctors have an
ethical responsibility at one point to
be like dude you're getting too close to
looking like handsome squidward you
gotta stop
but they don't do that they either go
sure blue just pay me and i'll [ __ ]
squeeze whatever weird [ __ ] you want in
your face
all right let's move on thank you
i've said too much
i've pissed off everybody and howie's
not coming on friday and simon cowell is
suing me
know how he's coming on friday um
oh speaking of people hating me
this is
um
i've been seeing a few posts like this
so told my tinder date that i watch h3
and i'm currently a member
and then i laughed out loud because the
tinder date hates me
and this is what i'm talking about we
need to reach across the aisle to the
manosphere and let them know that i can
be their daddy
and i'm talking to you tater tots
all the tater tots watching on tick tock
come join me i'll be daddy's [ __ ] for
you bro
so
uh
here's what her tinder date
said i don't [ __ ] with h3 a lot because
he like strongly against working out
which i think is kind of weird
i don't text
a lot but
is this normal like i don't think this
person needs to worry about working out
i think they maybe need to take a
grammar class
just like the cause and the
i don't [ __ ] with h3 a lot
cause
he's like strongly against working out
which i think is kind of weird i mean i
i follow it we we i know what he's it's
a little awkwardly worded
but this this is the kind of stuff
apparently somehow on the manosphere
this one stupid [ __ ] joke i made
about
not the working house not worth the time
it somehow reached the ends of the earth
with every male on tick tock and now
they all hate me
i'm against working out [ __ ]
what are you talking about
come on now
i'm daddy as hell oh you guys want to
exercise together you want to livestream
with me on the treadmill
i'll do it
i'll prove to you i need to prove to you
guys look at me there
look how big my nipples are bro
those are alpha nipples if i ever seen
them yeah
was there more was it just this one
screenshot
that was it there well yeah there's
another post that someone deleted with
something similar
a girl
this poor girl she posted a conversation
with her boyfriend delete
and i think it blew up way bigger than
she expected and she deleted it and
panic
because
i'm not going to say the name because
she posted the screenshot had his name
but it was a really funny name
and everybody was just clowning on her
boyfriend talking about what an idiot he
is
and um
oh he must he must have seen it but it
was this very similar conversation where
a girl was like
i like h3 they're funny whatever and
then the boyfriend's like i like joe
rogan
and it's like
there's two camps in the world
you know yeah alphas and betas
well don't forget the sigmas and the
sigmas well in the gamma males right
omega two oh mega males
zeta the few camps
did you say
yeah we said sigma
phi yeah in the final alpha
got him
i genuinely want to
i genuinely want to work on this i've
got to make segments that we can put on
tick tock for the alphas to see and be
like he's one of us
right maybe me doing like a heil hitler
while on a treadmill no
no we could we could workshop it that's
pretty alpha though right
and maybe i put oh you know what i could
put 20 pound weights and do a heil
hitler and then alternate
that's pretty sick dude that's uh that's
alpha dude we have a member for 25
months i said not gonna lie i thought
ethan was serious about not finding
purpose and working out just saying
dude okay even if i was though is it
really like that crazy that like you
have to hate me forever because i said
i'm saying
but no it was a joke obviously
you know i guess not obviously but it
was a joke
right tater tots you guys watching
this is my tater tot cam i have i have a
direct line into my haters it's really
great yeah shut up
yeah
so we're gonna work on that
i don't you guys have any ideas like
maybe um
oh i could be taking any other ideas but
you're doing the sigil
no that's the most alpha thing about it
yeah well what is joe rogan [ __ ] like
eating elk meat i can do that taking an
ice bath
nipples hard in the tub you gotta you
gotta make a milk out of your own [ __ ]
squeeze that and drink that maybe maybe
going into a sauna to the point of like
dying of of heat stroke
oh you you got to grow out your nipples
that's that yeah i'm working on that
yeah i'm currently working on that
oh
yeah
is this music copyrighted
i don't know
i'll pull it out
yeah okay but love made this which is a
fan cam we're gonna do this
may not like it
okay but this is peak male alpha right
here
hit him with it
bro that's the peak performance
damn
[Music]
exactly
the original song it makes it so good i
don't know it clicks with the
song i agree no it's really good
um so maybe like i could take an ice
bath and eat while eating elk meat and
raw yolk i mean that would that would
fly with them they would like that you
ever heard of the pacific crest uh trail
yeah that's the one that goes from
mexico to canada yeah
you could
hike that you could hike that i don't
see joe rogan hiking that [ __ ]
you could out alpha him you could go
across the bearing straight
right
i'm trying to think of things that i can
do either in the office or at my home
like napoleon
kick a punching bag
if i can just post a picture like this
you have a family joe you don't need to
do this but anyway no it's not for me to
judge
you should really make like working out
tick tocks i think that'd be hilarious
just you giving advice on i'm working
out
[Laughter]
maybe if i could master my spinning kick
that joe rogan loves he's the one kick
wonder
everyone talks about his mean spin kick
not gonna be a hater just seems like
he's pushing it like i i'm not who i
don't know anything about combat sports
that's a powerful kick but look he
pushes it at the end watch he pushes it
that's what miyagi does he's known to
have one on this some of the strongest
cakes
it's weird
yeah i think he just practiced this move
over and over
yeah but okay so i'm gonna get a [ __ ]
monster roundhouse down yeah good in
monster roundhouse people are uh
throwing out a lot of suggestions in the
donations here
uh eat another chip eat another fire uh
spicy chip well and smoke some gars yeah
we need some cars let's get let's get
some [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah add a
guard to the situation yeah i think it's
good yeah uh wait ethan you can just
make one of those intros like this is
what an alpha male looks like and i'll
just cut like a bunch of old clips
together i'll do a new alpha edit
okay okay that's interesting
um
chad says you can degrade some women
women yeah this is my wife ela she's a
she [ __ ] listen to me i can't even do
his wacky accent
knock it over my wife
all right well that's something coming
up do an episode entire episode on the
treadmill
that's pretty alpha
um god outflow would be like
any of you uh
uh i shouldn't even ask
it's inappropriate
okay
now i'm kind of curious no no no no no
if you think it's inappropriate yeah it
is
so there it is um
someone deep faked a little mermaid to
be white can you [ __ ] believe these
psychos this [ __ ] is so crazy we touched
on this yesterday just how psychotic
these people obsessed with ariel ariel
being white
credits to meemer artificial
intelligence scientist
he fixed the little mermaid and turned
the woke actor
she's black that doesn't make her a woke
actor you've watched people are woke
dude it's like that quartering name oh
you made it political by putting a black
what the [ __ ] woke actor
you don't know anything about her
into a ginger white girl he says he can
fix the whole movie when it comes out
it's over for woke cells do you
understand how [ __ ] lost you are if
you're gonna sit down and watch
this whole movie that you probably don't
even care about wouldn't watch otherwise
i knew it
i love this
please note this is purely educational
do not interpret this in a racist way oh
okay he used the word fix
what do you mean do not interpret this
in a racist way right fix that's a
problem yeah
um
interesting
yeah so apparently this guy got
immediately banned she's kind of funny
love that this guy and the one that he
tagged that actually made it uh we found
a backup
of the video i think it's in the dock
oh for real yeah all right here we go
i i present to you
the cutting edge of white supremacy
science
we have a whole basement of sweaty
overweight neck bearded white
supremacists
crunching on super computers that's
right
oh yeah that looks great
yeah everyone's gonna love that man
bro
just think about what you're doing in
life
in the drain
it's 20 22 and you're spending your time
changing someone's color in a movie
to be white
just just think about this
a fish
in a movie
it's a she's not even a real person it's
a fish person
fictional character
one of my favorite retorts i saw online
was like
well you guys didn't have a problem with
race swapping jesus
jesus of course middle eastern very dark
skin
so
[Music]
um
that's pretty fun pretty interesting
let's get on to the uh trying to work
towards the
hr segment
um here's one more chet hanks one that
we'll do hr
it's just awesome chet hanks friend of
the show enemy of the show really chet
hank speaking at recovery day in
winnipeg what is recovery day
for
for addicts
oh so it's a good thing
he's doing a great service there for the
people of winnipeg absolutely for the
five people here watching
well as we'll see changing lives
and you guys got a problem with the word
god
raise your hand if you got a problem
with the word god
zero people raising your hand you got a
problem with the word god
get the [ __ ] over yourself oh it's a
family event by the way
nobody's raising their hands
nobody's got a problem with god i didn't
know what he means by that
yeah i got a problem with god
it's awesome and i mean now with love
brother
do you want to drink [ __ ] knockoff
rc cola or a real [ __ ] coke
what every step that led me to here on
this stage talking to you guys
it's through the grace of god oh there's
parent there's parents walking up to the
stage to tell them to please stop
cursing because they have kids there
yo y'all [ __ ] with god or what
y'all [ __ ] get down with god y'all
rub dicks with god like me with dogs
like that
hey thanks for coming out
what grade are you in son
that's joker brains act
yeah if you ain't down with god you need
to [ __ ] leave
hey little hey little boy you go to
church on sunday get the [ __ ] out of
here
okay
take your kids watch your [ __ ] mouth
oh my
god they said please watch your mouth i
have kids here and he says you watch
your [ __ ] mouth it's through the
grace of god
well can we get a little grace here
where's god's grace man
no way this just happened
yeah okay
take your kids watch your [ __ ] mouth
dude this is such a train wreck
what is this
celebrating recovery
did
what's he recovered from exactly he's
worse than he ever was
his brain on god is not better than his
brain on whatever [ __ ] he was before
say get him back on and
if you don't like gone cigarettes well
[ __ ] you
this is like belligerent
come on up here buddy
i don't think you can
what he's trying to fight
yeah i think he's trying to get a kid on
stage i'm used to this [ __ ] you guys
i don't know
dude he doesn't want you dropping he
doesn't want you cursing around his kids
like
he's like yo i speak from the heart and
that means drop saying [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i'm used to attacking these
parents in santa barbara
they ain't [ __ ] yo what's up people in
santa barbara there's like
love clap there's only like 10 people
there
dude tom hanks come get your son
holy [ __ ]
if you don't want your children to be
exposed to profanity just take them
somewhere else right now respectfully
this is a
this is a family-friendly event the
children area was about 50 meters off
from the stage
respectfully well i didn't share that
with anybody
i tried to blend in did he really think
he's doing something how he's pacing
backwards he thinks he's like tim
robbins right now this great masterpiece
yo if you don't [ __ ] with god
then i'm gonna [ __ ] you
and your kids
this is what pinocchio grows up to be
oh pinocchio where she didn't become a
real boy now to revisit and go deeper
pinocchio's like quit turn me back into
a mannequin
i don't like this i have anybody i never
advertised that [ __ ]
i don't want anybody to know because i
just wanted to be treated like everybody
else but i'm telling you now and if you
guys are looking at me right now and
you're thinking oh man he probably
thinks he's so much [ __ ] better than
me [ __ ] this guy like that
chill
the performer before him was a drag
queen from canada's drag race
nobody's thinking that he thinks he's
people thinking you're unhinged
belligerent [ __ ] you he's hot he must be
high
maybe he's on that chapter now seems
like he just did a few lines he's not
high enough
chill out dude
man he probably thinks he's so much
[ __ ] better than me [ __ ] this guy
like that kook that was up here a few
seconds ago bro
he's insulting the last a drag queen he
called him a kook
why is he there i don't know this is
crazy this isn't a bit like this isn't a
bit right now
oh whoa
see i didn't watch this whole video i
just saw the first part oh my god
i said it before and i'll say it again
that's not tom's son that's forrest's
son right there
i don't think i've ever heard you say
that i'm speaking up louder now that's
forest
forest junior that's true that is for
son we always wonder what happened to
him yeah
he was in character when he was
conceived
looking at me right now and you're
thinking oh man he probably thinks he's
so much [ __ ] better than me [ __ ] this
guy like that kook that was up here a
few seconds ago i love that he goes you
probably think i'm so much better than
you like this other [ __ ] loser before
me that i am so much better than
life was like a box of chocolates jesus
i bet tom hanks didn't think this was
the chocolate he was gonna get from his
life you never know what you're gonna
get
that's a good metaphor for kids one
chocolate is like his son that looks
just like him and is normal and then one
chocolate is chet
you never know what you're going to get
that's true or worse i've never spoken
mr hanks
oh my god
i don't care
today
i don't care
today
no people are leaving
look at the people are clearing out this
one dude's like
i don't care
today
i don't care
these girls were huge fans of the drag
queen they walked off after hearing
check call them kooks
this might be the best meltdown i've
ever seen on stage i don't think i've
ever seen anything like this
this is really incredible
if you think that about me today i don't
care
it is what it is
yeah this is the time
the time is right now the place is right
now there's nobody left i don't care
substance abuse and addiction are
serious issues people can suffer with
recovery is a hard journey and long
journey helping people before you heal
is not only harmful to your own progress
but harmful to the people you're trying
to help
helping people stage words
what did they mean helping people oh
before you yeah yeah so they're saying
he hasn't healed himself he's not ready
to help others that's right i think he
might actually still be high so that's
probably the first step in being sober
yeah
the place is right now
i don't care
this is hot talk
that offends you i apologize
oh that's nice i thought he was gonna
say
[ __ ] you
yeah yo i need this whole thing this is
i only got two minutes uh can we find
this whole performance [ __ ] you
i mean this is really
something special going on here yeah i
mean uh i don't know if this was really
broadcast or anything it just seems to
be somebody recording on their cell
phone but you can see if that account
has more videos
yeah chet hanks actually uh here's uh
geppetto aka his dad
she built him
it's an incredible rich opportunity he
[ __ ] with wishing stars out here
yeah
it's great masterpiece pretty
interesting
it sure is a masterpiece there
i think tommy's just start taking less
roles and more time
just a week ago they the whole family
had a public dinner at a restaurant and
it looks like tom hanks wife rita was
crying
really yes was chet there yeah how many
kids do they have two
just chat and the normal one
uh that at least that is not rita's uh
son right they have different mom right
wait but rita's crying at dinner his mom
is jenny
exactly
enough
um there is a part two on there
that's what i'm saying i need more all
right
four more minutes for you inject this
into my [ __ ] veins bro i need this
whole damn thing we have dodged
four more minutes oh my god i'm so lucky
to have this
and nobody's seen this only at 66 likes
holy [ __ ] the perilous
perilous treacherous
destiny that i was creating for myself
every day gotta do something yo there is
literally nobody there now like they're
panning back and forth there's nobody
there i'll do anything
to just not feel like this
in this moment
so i did one thing that i knew always
made me feel just a little good about
myself which was bust down on the ground
and knock out a hundred burpees
i busted down on the ground and knocked
out a hundred burpees burpees [ __ ]
for addiction y'all alpha behavior
obviously that's basically on par with
keemstar's take a couple sips of beer
threesomes take some well no that's
better than beer than three sips of beer
actually
that's better
i felt a little bit better about myself
after that and i told myself i'll keep
doing this every day i'll do at least
100 burpees every day burpees for god
y'all
why is it
why does no one like cut the mic
i don't think anybody there should know
he's the headliner
they may have paid him to be there very
well probably
you know
like he's their celebrity headline
chetana
yo this man bust down 100 burpees a day
because it's something that's what it
started off as
i never stopped pacing
i never stopped that's what i'm saying
he's working the crowd there's nobody
there
when in the first part there was like
you know 20 30 people shoulder shoulder
here
is it giving you i felt gay for survive
yeah i felt worthless i felt worthless
people are saying
i felt gay we got to get fousey up here
man to share the stage with this legend
like that just based on what they told
me
[Laughter]
so inspirational man oh
hanks was the headline speaker
hey yeah they ain't cutting that off
they played good money
good money for him to show up just give
me 500 every day winnipeg's website
hanks was the events headline speaker in
a lineup that also included canada's
drag race alumni juice box boa kendall
gender and cows and american actor
tony dennison you gotta love that he
just went straight for that other
person's throat
give me 500 bucks on a place to do my
burpees man then we're good
that's what they paid somebody said chet
right
his son oh is it the other way around is
colin hanks not
i know they have different moms right
shoes
yeah gay and colin hangs
chet probably had reverse do yeah they
thought they were
state of mind
long story short
i got in really good shape from doing
that i got out of rehab i was so
thankful just to be alive and sober i
was broke i had no idea how i was going
to make a living for myself you were
broke
stop with the poor actor jesus jesus
christ you know what i mean like don't
even act like you're broke and didn't
have money stop you know like this dude
had a private
it seems like you always had a fat
apartment like on the beach in santa
monica you probably was at some like
four seasons recovery clinic
stop it bro i felt worthless
what else did you feel food i felt ugly
what happened i felt gay
the worst thing
his when he tries to stick the landing
on that in my face
like that
like i just did like that just based on
what they told me
oh my god tom has four kids who said he
had two
he has four kids apparently okay
sorry i don't know all the all the lords
about the hank's clan when rita was
crying there were two sons present
that's what i know
you think it was chet you think it was
from this
no this uh this was before i mean this
was after we got colin chet elizabeth
and truman
who was elizabeth and truman what do
they look like
are there pictures of them i just want
to know what they look like
like are they more calling or more
let's see because he's such an
incredible
colin looks just like his dad dude that
kid looks like bob dylan what like bob
dylan has a kid i swear to god that's
like spitting image bob dylan huh
look up young bob dylan thanks
uh no i i see it
dude who is this
oh i guess i see it i see it in her face
she an actress
i don't know i don't recognize her holy
[ __ ] he does like exactly like dude bob
dylan she's crazy
just pop it up show the people
you know
spit an image of the man look at that
young bob dylan is tom hanks son
yeah alex i see the resemblance yeah
thank you thanks for saying that
all righty uh chet please inspire us
more i didn't care i was just as
grateful then
at the beginning wait somebody in chat
says they dated chat if that's true
reach out to
um
one of these guys on discord definitely
want to hear about that what do we do
about it
i said i'm going to keep my life just as
simple as i out here in the world as i
did in rehab because when i was in rehab
just doing those burpees and it wasn't a
nice rehab there was no massages and
horseback rides it was just a motel six
looking building out of the desert where
all i did was do burpees read journal
and walk laps around the place no self i
was more at peace just doing that than i
had been during all the extravagant
all the other stuff that i had been
doing up until that so when i got out i
told myself i'm going to keep my life
just this simple
in january
i i've been posting my workouts posting
my process my structure my routine my
burpees my journals my meditation so on
and so forth for the mind body and soul
just posting it because i took pride in
it what ended up happening was it
resonated with a lot of people people
started reaching out to me
is someone checking donations because
this shit's insane
i j i dated chet a year ago around this
time we were photographed together in
santa monica i want to give him a chance
based on his public perception he was
sober he was always kind to me
but needs to feel nurtured to heal okay
there you go from olivia
she dated chet chetna
yeah you know he's obviously just a
little bit damaged
olivia
he's feeling a little bit gay
you is someone vetting these though
because i i don't want to miss great
comments like that
of course um
yes i dated him if you google olivia j
and chet hanks you can see i'm telling
the truth not trying to cloud chase just
being honest
um if you have a discord yeah if you
have a discord please reach out to
anybody hey let me google it what's your
name what do you like come
it was posted just like a moment before
uh we started talking about it
all right so what's your name olivia
olivia j
j
and chet
inks
oh
like that's just based on what they told
me
um this is them this is she's in the
chat shout out olivia
friends of the show
direct connection
oh
no pictures please i see what's up
olivia
all right
cool that's cool
i thought i might as well start a
platform to be able to share this
knowledge forever who else is drawn to
it so i started a business the hanks fit
self mastery program on january 1st of
this year
i had used my
i had like
i had like eight thousand dollars left
to my name i spent 7 500 of it
to a coach to a mentor to teach me how
to set up this business oh my god i was
spending the last of my money on a dream
my first month running that business i
made 50k okay it all came out what are
you doing
these people they need some inspiration
he's talking about burpees and how he's
trying to pitch his
[ __ ] coaching business to them he's
about to plug hustler's university what
the [ __ ] this is insane is one of his
tips always be plugging
doesn't matter when or how like that
just based on what they told me
what the hell
back right away
now it's a seven figure business
it started off at 50k now i'm on track
to be doing 100k a month how's that
supposed to help them you're tom hanks
son
i've realized my purpose you want to get
fit and appeal to the tater thoughts i
know a guy now
100 burpees a day hundred burpees a day
hey take the hanks fit challenge he's in
your dms so maybe you can reach out he
blocked me oh
yeah
which is to simply be the best version
of myself and then live as an example if
you follow me on instagram you'll see it
every day i wake up throw another plug
follow me on instagram
do my coaching
i'm a great opportunity i'm a great role
model for you i'm like this kook who
went before me
this is nuts 4 45 in the morning every
day i do 100 burpees
you mentioned that you mentioned the 100
several times
chat hundred burpees hanks
at the gym i felt ugly eat the exact
meals that i need to eat for my goals i
meditate and then for the rest of the
day all day i'm servicing my clients
i've realized
that the key to everything
is simply surrendering your own will to
be in god's will to realize that it's
not about you it's not about what you
feel like doing it's about simply
becoming the best version of yourself so
that you can live as an example because
that's exactly what i needed i needed
someone to show me day in day out no
excuses that they're gonna hold their
word
and do exactly what they need wait what
the [ __ ] was that in service
so yeah okay so wow that was that was
wild man that was wide
burpees for god y'all
burpees for god did he mention he does a
hundred burpees
actually interestingly
just this morning
he was doing burpees for god i think
here let's see
there he goes that's my boy burpees for
gone what's up aren't you supposed to
jump that's like that's like a half
burpee that's normal burpees but for god
burpees you don't have to jump yeah
he's doing a prayer every time he stands
up yeah god bless ready what's that
bismuth
yo
he's still going there's like 20 stories
of him doing burpees
and they all look exactly the same
oh [ __ ]
this guy is so privileged and he wants
not to be so bad it's interesting
he paid his dues
yeah tuesday
sure did
longtime friend of the show since
gamergunk that's why it was kind of
funny awkward meeting him after channel
5 video
i don't know how to use discord though i
boomer energy sorry guys that's from
olivia his ex-girlfriend so you met him
after the channel 5 video
she was trying to give him a chance she
said wow
i do think he's a sweet sensitive side
so obviously
you know
i'm not judging you for dating
you know that man does 100 burpees today
he's probably got crazy stamina
all right let's let's let's set it up
for um the hr that took way longer than
i thought
oh god i also got to watch austin
mcbroom getting knocked out
there's there's too much let's do hr and
then we'll talk about austin
twelve steps what is this is this she
posted the other day that he's been
sober for a year
that's pretty good
yeah we love that for him
i sure do
i just don't know if god your brain on
god is better i just don't know
um well
uh should we talk about awesome mcbroom
getting knocked the [ __ ] out or should
we do the hr segment and we also have
dirty dom [ __ ] we've taken too long to
get through this [ __ ]
well the the chat thing
ended up being
we didn't know there was more
okay let's do it let's do a poll here uh
hr segment
austin mcbroom getting knocked the f out
room getting ko'd
or dirty dom calling me out
dirty
i don't know how it's spelled i'm just
writing dirty dirty dumb
it's gonna be no competition this poll
you think hr out yeah yeah i that's the
one i want to do but
i'm gonna try i'm still gonna try to get
to everything i'm gonna go for it
but i just wanna
uh feel out the audience yeah exactly
we'll do everything though regardless so
don't worry
get your [ __ ] ass up um yeah
yeah hr segments winning a lot of
interest in the awesome groom stuff
though but
clear winners hr segment so when we get
set up for that i'm gonna go use the
bathroom because i've been hitting this
game uh the gamers sup
this gamer subs got me all jacked up
okay cool
thank you for the gift dude
what liquor this man's name is billiam
what liquor hello
hello all right
are we all set up i'm just gonna go to
the bathroom there's really yeah it is
then
for hr
hello
oh another from another follow-up five
dollars from olivia yep a friend
introduced us after the channel 5 video
she didn't know
who he was until after she introduced us
five dollars
wait so
the friend introduced you but she didn't
know
he was
tom hanks son
his name's olivia can you perhaps make
us a powerpoint interesting we can
follow this whole timeline yeah we love
powerpoint hello
i was just diagnosed with a new heart
arrhythmia
i am so scared for what
it's to come but you guys make me feel a
lot better well i'm sorry to hear that
clumsy hope
i hope it uh turns out to be something
manageable
um when i bend over my fupa unzips my
pants does this happen to anyone else
[Music]
oh
i can't i can't i can't say that that
has happened to me anyone anybody have
that issue
no can't say the same you'll ask ethan
he's the fupa king obviously so
we'll see what he has to say i wish they
knew about omega verse
well now we do
should i google that omegaverse am i
gonna regret it megaverse
[Music]
the best buffalo chicken calzones is a
subgenre of speculative erotic fiction
uh-oh originally a sub-genre of a lot of
erotic slash fiction
um
all right i'm a little scared to read
into this more stories in the genre are
premised on societies wherein humans are
divided into a dominant hierarchy of
dominant alphas neutral betas and
submissive omegas determining how they
interact with one another well that's
just a brave new world
the knot
that's literally the
[Music]
the plot of uh brave new world
uh sounds sick
[Music]
well now we know about it now we know
about it thank you shout out shout out
let's let's read this i didn't even look
at it i didn't see the chat everybody's
saying no stop oh my god don't google it
well now we know too late i mean the
wikipedia page is pretty neutral
everyone's going crazy about this yeah
what the [ __ ] what's going on i get to
look into it more i guess
the omega verse very controversial it
seems
people are saying not the same not the
same as brave new world okay fair enough
they they did have like a whole alpha
beta
thing in brave new world if i recall
it's been a while like high school
[Music]
ah
so yeah well now we know okay and
obviously the hr segment has won so we
can close that poll thank you very much
that was a good poll i saw people saying
good cold thank you thank you
saw some uh
in the what saw teddy fresh stegosaurus
sweater in the wild in dublin today
shout out hey shout out to dublin
shout out
i just found out i got diabetes a week
ago what
i'm sorry to hear that there's a lot of
people being diagnosed with horrible
things that are
donating to us right now so
by the way speaking of diabetes worry
about that
something i'm working on is a low
insulin diet
which means like
no sugar no sugar no carbs
and like if you eat sugar or carbs you
got to pair it with like fat and protein
so the insulin doesn't spike okay and
you digest it slower did you did you get
warned by your doctor about no potential
i just know i'm
i just [ __ ] know that
that it might be on the horizon
yeah but you know i noticed something
about myself
that when i eat
like simple carbs if i have like pizza
or a bagel or
something like that
with lots of bread i just get so [ __ ]
tired and foggy
i just feel like [ __ ]
rick and i found when i eat
like
fatty proteins and stuff like that like
this morning
it's not a fad diet bro this is my own
invention
it's just like uh
it's just what makes me feel good right
so like this morning i had
plain greek yogurt
perfect food for not spiking insulin
it's just
fatty
lots of protein no added sugar
and then i had a one hard-boiled egg
and um
a nectarine
you know
sounds good feels good yeah you know
[ __ ]
30 ounces of gamer
which has no sugar
but yeah
it's good i like it anyway let's do some
hr
[Music]
so
as we mentioned here we are
i will be acting today as hr which is a
little bit of a
conflict of interest being is that i'm
the boss
well hr
would work for you anyways right so
that's true that's true
but i think
generally speaking you don't want to
have to go to your boss to complain
about stuff sure
but well forget about that
you know
luckily i'm so inviting and uh you guys
wouldn't worry about anything like that
right definitely
definitely
so we have several conflicts brewing
behind the scenes between
the crew and i'm basically here to
mediate it
i'm here to some may even directly
involve you ethan
okay which is a written that's a
conflict of interest i suppose but well
i'll try my best to be impartial but
so let's let's just get started i mean
okay
our first conflict here
so i'm eating
where is it
[Music]
first conflict is love and a b
now
yeah you should come over uh oh and uh
love can you um log into your mobile
unit here
oh okay yeah yeah it's it's important
that we meet face to face for this you
guys know right to really resolve this
now it now maybe your
your body language is already a problem
for me this isn't resolution by the way
you're talking over the course i don't
have the confidence that bradley martin
has just spread my legs in front of the
camera can you talk the other way
because it's if you you know this kid
yeah that's absolutely like this is very
ready
non-confrontational
so this complaint came to me through a b
he filed a complaint with me that love
had done something
that he didn't find proper
love posted the photo of abe actually do
we have the photo in question
i was doing my job a.k.a
right well hold on let me let me finish
don't get me wrong okay sorry it's all
right
a little bit can someone like me the
photo just for context here
it's in the top of the dock um but oh i
have it right here it was somewhat on my
can you park love this
yeah
excuse me
yeah so
abe has a weird aversion to this
um
he told me it was improper of love to
post this picture on twitter now what
was the post you tweeted love
i was i just posted this picture and a
quotation saying
this is what too much flakka will do to
you
pretty funny meme
isn't right mr ryan so love or i mean ab
had filed a request for me
uh complaining that
he should have asked permission before
posting this photo
and he didn't like it is that right evie
well i said the night prior this is the
worst photo i've ever seen of me this
photo is going to hunt me forever
and then i woke up the next day and saw
this posted on twitter
so yes i was like who posted this
wait that timeline doesn't make sense
right or guess it maybe it does it makes
sense i posted that maybe an hour before
um
you woke up maybe so yeah maybe it does
make sense here
well to be fair it was already on the
subreddit with like three thousand
points right
your problem was like someone within
this organization someone i thought was
yeah someone i thought was a friend
betrayed me so
let me let me ask you first where and
when did you say that did you say that
on the show
no i said it in the in the group chat
did you yeah
i did not see that no well here
hold on a sec i'm gonna mediate he did
say in the group chat we have this is
the worst photo of me ever i saw that
i perceived that personally as like well
it's just you know
it's funny
but to you it represented an existential
threat to your self-image
yeah
to my being in a way
like i don't even know it's like looking
at it right now like i'm trying to look
away and i can't
it's like eating at my soul
yeah oh we have that we actually have
the conversation here brah who posted
this 10 30 a.m
dan not me
an immediate accusation of love can we
delete it
i think we weren't we didn't know if he
was serious or not
ultimately it was conveyed that it was a
serious request and then love you'd
erased it right
dan right done yeah i was not being or
something oh dan did it yeah so right
[Music]
so love what what do you want to
basically say in your defense here so
what i want to say like i would never go
out of my way to screenshot this from
the episode i saw it was literally the
top reddit post right so i basically
just mirrored a reddit post to twitter
um you know just like
i know i know stuff like that does good
on got on twitter so i posted on twitter
and uh
you know um
i guess it's a fair point to to to have
me well the thing is i post so much i
probably post like
100 pieces of content maybe a week like
between all social media right
and for me to
ask
every
time i i guess it's something i do see
the see the difference but
uh
yeah just because it blew up on reddit
and stuff i didn't end up asking but i
probably would have asked if it wasn't
on reddit
i understand i guess if he didn't read
the group chat
ahead of time
did you read the group chat actually
no i i am completely i almost thought
you didn't say it in the group chat and
i thought you said it on in person in
the show or in the studio when i was not
there because i did not actually see
that in the group shout out at all
um um uh pfp accio says this is my new
wallpaper on my phone yep oh it's
definitely gonna be after this
it's gonna be everywhere
now i want to say first of all
when i i was i thought love did a great
job as as you know
as the general or whatever i was like
this is good content yeah so i guess
maybe
there needs to be a protocol should we
ask the permission from crew members
before posting their photo no this is
the first time i've ever asked for
anything ever be deleted okay could i
could i interject a little bit there i
think the other way around would be
better if you ever have and by the way
if i ever post something of course i
will delete it i mean i'm not bound to
whatever i post you know just remove it
but if you guys ever feel like yeah i
didn't really like this moment
[Music]
could we give me a warning before
because i usually prepare i this post
was scheduled yeah uh and stuff like
that so i prepared stuff uh before yeah
so maybe the other way around would be
good that's fair actually can i say love
i don't think me and you have a beef
i think ethan wanted to talk about this
ethan wanted to bring more attention to
this this is the sec this wasn't my idea
i didn't put this segment love can you
mediate me and ethan
this was a huge problem you guys were
having and and may i say uh uh uh maybe
christmas is coming up can i get some
merch going with this photo perhaps if i
get it cut
you'll get all of it no actually i
wouldn't even want to do that for a cut
you'll get all of it bro i mean even
though it's gonna be everywhere now dude
you'll get all of it
what
[Music]
come on this is it this isn't this is a
deep rooted childhood problem looking at
this photo so so what's the root of your
insecurity that i'm carrying i i don't
know me my siblings are all kind of
[ __ ] up like that i don't really know
why if you guys ever see me with
band-aids or cuts on my faces because
like if i have a pimple i can't just
leave it alone i have to like pick at it
that's why my hair is always messed up i
cut my own hair and now i'm it's like
the visual representation of how i feel
i'm just looking at it
so you're getting psychology
i'm kind of wondering here was it
actually ethan's fault or was it you
because i did not bring this up with pr
or with uh what did i do hr
yeah i mean
exactly yeah he says we need to remove
this and okay that's right yeah okay
yeah i did it
this is ethan's fault oh thank you love
and you know what uh i have a little bit
of a compromise here um
uh i have a tweet drafted here
just let me let me i'm not gonna tweet
it directly i i of course need your
permission before not at this point but
i was thinking maybe i could post this
it's like a little bit of an in between
um
i think that could work you know i think
it might be a good two because the tweet
was doing extremely well for the 10
minutes it was up yeah
a heavily blurred pixelated
photo of
abe
does this work for you baby yeah there
are a lot of other stills too from the
episode that well this i like this one
specifically
i like this one though yeah all right so
i'm gonna go ahead and tweak that are
you all good
or i'm cool with that yeah yeah yeah
okay cool all right i just squeezed it
it's nice
you mentioned that you thought your eyes
were going in different directions yeah
the buck too yeah
the crazy hair i'm okay with the hair my
hair is always [ __ ] up what else is it
in here with that ah
i feel like i look like mr bean
mr bean right yeah i got a cut on my
face a little tiny one right there on
the left
i just wait i didn't know stop
right there
yes oh yeah right there
i mean that's not so bad but
i just
uh is scary to me
well i was i see i saw some person say
um
normalized not making fun of people's
looks and you know you know i'll be the
first one to say ap is a very handsome
man very very hard everyone says and so
i'm not making fun of history
enough to sabotage my heartthrob status
by posting this
well i i know i i that i think is where
you
might
be think a little bit different about
this because this is just like temporary
we all know you're a very handsome man
your clone is not perfect no i i know
i'm [ __ ] in the head no i know it's
not you guys i know i definitely know
it's me yeah i yeah when i look at this
photo
yeah it doesn't i have no perception
change you know what i
of
mean
no i i know it's me like my whole life
everyone can tell me one thing it's just
i don't know
it's affecting my siblings too i don't
know where we get it from
marek mari says uh embrace the meme
people will love you oh i'm always you
guys know you guys know i'm always down
for the show i almost
puked my i mean i did puke my guts out
but i almost had my like uh
intestines explode so this is the same
merch is a hard note from uab
i'm telling you
cleaning up this holiday season
people are clamoring for the baby hoodie
think about it think about it you don't
have to answer now
okay i'll do it and i'll do it because
it's already gonna be everywhere after
this
yeah you free yourself
by putting this on a shirt
so at this point i'm feeling like i kind
of missed out on likes yesterday if we
backtrack now you know
that would have been like a viral tweet
right so you'd feel now that a little
bit better that a b
told you to remove it
yeah cause you know
i take pride in like
get like posting something that just
blows up that feels so good it was a
good post
yeah
so now i feel like damn like damn we
missed out some likes bro [ __ ] i feel
like i bring enough likes to even it out
we've had stupid photos of me before
abe says
i bring clout
i just already bring so much clout
let this one photo go he says i just
feel like yeah i gave my soul
i gave my soul on this day
they gave my new teddy freaks you're
gonna make so much money from this photo
though i'm telling you oh my god
really a beaver all right well um
are we resolved here um
yes love i didn't i i i never took it
personal
oh that's weird because you did dm me
and say that i [ __ ] can't stand that
love character
well yeah i was actually a little bit
threatened by about this tweet right
here i never had any conversations on
the side everything is what you guys
already saw hold on he posted he did
you tweeted this under it bruh i legit
want to know who posted this you knew
you posted it too like i am the dude who
posts stuff on instagram usually well
you aren't turning a little bit demanded
accountability wait that does come off
threatening
that is very like that is like sure i i
am the one making the issue here maybe i
want to know who's [ __ ] me over yeah
because we have a private chat well i
got a twitter out of public no i did i
did on twitter no one answered i mean on
instagram the chat
yeah so what how does going to twitter
and posting it gonna get you quicker
because i i cause i know you liked it so
much ethan the night before that
i thought maybe you posted it because i
didn't think love would do that to me
that's why i was so hurt oh yeah
only i would do that to you only you
would do it yeah
i am confused about the timelines here
hmm
wait what are you trying to dodge
accountability
no no no no i definitely posted i'm just
wondering where when i posted it do we
know exactly i think it was literally
right after the show ended
yeah so it's not when you guys woke up i
posted it after the show right yeah like
i remember it was on no it's at 10
o'clock
10 in the morning
10
[Music]
yeah it says 10 30 a.m in the screenshot
of the original tweet the only thing is
maybe i asked who posted it on twitter
before the group chat i don't know
i was in a i was in a weird state
yeah
i was still i was still recovering from
the day before
well i guess i schedule it yeah i don't
know
i guess it says hr
i'm gonna have to make a verdict on this
one
i think
on one hand
i see where you're coming from with like
you see that the one photo that you just
it brings out like the biggest
insecurities right it just makes you
feel bad yeah
but on the other hand
i'm kind of with love and that i
wouldn't necessarily think that i would
have to ask for permission but it's good
that we know that now
you do not have to ask for permission no
i i hear you loud and clear you know
there are boundaries
and if we get a picture of a b
we need to ask his permission before we
posted love you're asking
i appreciate it yeah i have reputation
you're asking and then
in the future
if there's a conflict in the office
maybe
um
i would i would avoid
making death threats on on twitter to
your co-workers okay yeah
cause that scared me a lot you know
but you know i just want to make some
clear to you so i'm still clear like i
pro i would not have posted it if it
didn't blew up i would not have posted
it
you said on the show like you're you do
anything for the show so i thought this
would be included but yeah
uh
but yeah you know i i i even also noted
like
you knew you looked pretty messed up
after you had puked and everything and
stuff like that and you still came back
on the show i thought that was pretty
heroic of you so i gotta give you some
credit absolutely
oh for sure
you came back you sat down after that
horrible horrible hour on the bathroom
so i'm gonna give you some credit too
i had mad respect for abe he went
through the tren man he went to war for
us on monday
yeah that was rough
mad respect by the way thank you to
tatyana
huge dono hello
it's my 24th birthday glad i got to
enjoy it watching the real one podcast
happy birthday peace and love thank you
guys for always making hard days easier
thank you tom taco
love you money on your birthday i don't
know
yeah
but okay so so
is there anything you guys want to close
here um
wrap this hr up up
i
i think we're good i think there's this
piece i've said sorry i don't know if
i've ever got a sorry about the threats
on twitter i'm sorry love okay thank you
you have actually threatened me before
oh okay interesting oh this doesn't
sound resolved you are the only one
who's ever threatened me in this office
you have said
once i almost stepped in front of you by
accident during a photo and you said you
better not or people get pissed off
then you told me once when i responded
to one i was going to respond to one of
your tweets messing with you you said
you better not post that
evie did that everyone saw it right you
literally told me to remove something i
just posted so i don't know
but okay whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay guys wow we got it
we were so close i know we were so close
okay we're good we're good are you
literally almost you murdered lovebot
the original one oh man this goes deeper
than i thought this goes deeper than i
thought that's true
um you did knock over love i gotta blame
for that i did not do that no now stop
it we saw your foot kick the damn thing
if you did that everyone saw that
okay guys with this it goes too deep you
ran over him you ran him over a few
times
you hit him with a guess for a gag bro
that was for a gag
thank you love and i was having fun
all right guys we got to move on thank
you guys uh clearly a great moment of
healing wait wait we're supposed to
restore trust by that's that we're
getting to that so we are going to uh
perform a trust fall
to demonstrate
the bridge of
yeah love let me trust let me catch that
new bot real quick i don't know how oh
you're catching me not sure how this is
gonna work here with the love bot of
course oh i'm sure he could hold me up
you got me buddy right dan doesn't trust
me he's putting down pillows i do not no
i don't consent to this all right love
let's go
what the [ __ ]
ah
all right uh wow wow
i think you're supposed to count down
before you fall back
yeah i told you i wasn't ready bro you
gotta dive in all right now great this
trust fall created a new hr
incident
thank you to love and ap i don't think
we've resolved anything really here
today but um
[Music]
actually caused more more trouble uk
oh [ __ ] i think love's hurt maybe he's
frozen he's fine he's good
he's good thank you guys thank you
frozen
all right
he's fine everybody don't worry about
love cut his bike please we don't
really need to be here
it's distracting
all right
off to a great start up next we have
ian and cameron
having a big issue here
thank you and thank you by the way
on a serious note to abe for even
uh participating in this oh yeah when
the picture right there you know
anything for the show i appreciate that
and that's true i mean look at this
okay so
damn they're already beefing
okay so okay all right
can i just preface this a little bit
i've never seen cam get worked up except
when it comes to this situation okay
all right yeah yeah okay this is
interesting so that's how you know it's
important i had cameron come to me and
file a hr complaint
[Music]
cameron thinks he looks like
or is he i mean this goes to the
stranger things charlie don't show this
just yet because we gotta preface hold
on i don't i don't agree with this
framing here yes hold on
well the complaint came to me from
cameron
what's the name of the actor he he wants
to be like joe kiri
i think joe or what's his name and think
yes it is what's the name and stranger
thing steve harris
hold on hold on hold on
so cameron that's me thinks he's steve
harrington of the
of the uh stranger things crew
no no no no no no you have to grant
someone the permission to speak okay
i'm setting this up guys guys guys this
is conflict resolution okay permission
to speak boss no not yet
denied denied
so um of the whole crew this is how
cameron sees himself he's steve
the badass
jock
ladies guy
this is this is how you see yourself
right you can't you can't permission to
speak yes yes yes don't let them speak
too much
just answer the question i disagree with
this entire framing right now this was
not my complaint okay go ahead cam
let me
set this up
we're planning a halloween episode
and a part of it is we're gonna be
dressed up as uh stranger things
characters for it you know spoiler but
you know
tune in guys uh but uh so i was told
that olivia and i would be dressed up as
steve harrington
and the hell told you that olivia told
me this we would be dressed up as okay
hold on hold on ian and
the
ethan hawk's daughter's name i forgot so
she would be ethan hawke's daughter yeah
and we would be wearing steve the
scoopsahoy outfit and i was stoked and
okay that's and that's it and then for
whatever reason okay ian has an issue
this man is like okay
go ahead
and talk yet what the hell is going on
okay so now cam
you made it sound pretty innocent you're
just saying well i was i was given a
role and i was enthused to take on that
role
and then ian for whatever reason
the scene is fuming right now let's take
it away from me uh go ahead and now you
tell us what happened okay we had a
lighthearted conversation see look at
he's so anticipated please try not to
mess him up
write him up citations
this has to be a citation
we are trying to resolve conflict here
if you could avoid
man spreading on ian please during the
negotiation okay
we were having a conversation about
which person in office is which
character from stranger things and i was
given steve harrington right out there
that was not what happened
the scoops ahoy olivia conversation came
way later no hold on hold on guys guys
cam
you got to let ian speak
okay and then and then you can rebut
unplug it unplug that mic it's important
it's important during hr uh conflict
resolution
it's called radical listening cameron
you need to just listen to what he's
saying
and then take the time to respond
afterwards great
so
i put forward in a light-hearted jovial
way
that cameron
if he were a stranger thinks character
would be
one of the buyers
boys one of the buyer's boys jonathan
byers
will's older brother will's older
brother
i got some agreement in the office at
the time this guy yes if you can show
okay this is obviously cam
okay that is such a cameron character
cameron freaked out went rogue was
smashing things
was [ __ ] on the floor in the office
making a big fuss
saying no i'm steve i think cameron
is a little upset because he was called
a hufflepuff the other week and now he's
lashing out against the rest of us and i
don't think that it's very fair i feel
like i made a pretty
pretty just observation here
and then it turned into a whole drama
where everyone's saying who's who
now
samantha
are you present
present present samantha has to put
together these costumes for the
halloween episode
so i think samantha has some sort of
oversight on making the costumes would
you agree
on who gets which costume i i would
agree would you say that
jonathan byers is a good fit for cameron
i do think so
okay now now hold on here
no so i'm trying to understand where the
conflict comes from so ian
kim you want to be steve
yes i was giving ian
jonathan
witnesses here no hold on i i'm willing
to be a witness ian if you need me
okay hold on a b okay hold on hold on
but before you even get to who said
you're who
what is the problem necessarily with you
playing this character instead of steve
what's the issue at heart here okay
there's three reasons why i want to be
steve okay number one i love that
scoop's ahoy outfit i think it would be
fun to wear that fair number two i like
steve and number three both the buyers
boys creative as they are are boring as
[ __ ] characters and i don't want to be a
boring [ __ ] character i get a monotone
sometimes but you know i hate
this character in particular he's a
creep in the first season he was taking
creep shots of nancy
so do you think that
you take it personally when they say
you're a jonathan not a steve i think
they're commenting on on your
personality no i just don't i just don't
like this character don't like him yeah
don't want to have anything to do with
it i'm sure they see virtue in this
boring ass guy but this thing me
and by the same token are you trying to
go ahead may i add yes
there's more to the story too go ahead i
believe
ian's a little bitter
because he wanted to be interesting
hopper
but he was typecast
as yuri the smuggler double-crossing
comic relief interesting and i think
there's a little bit of a freudian death
drive here and he's trying to bring
everybody down
with him that is interesting uh
observation of course conjecture
ian do you are you trying to make some
statement on cam's character by putting
him in with jonathan instead of steve
what do we do i feel like most people
would agree with me that this is a
jonathan right next to me i see
a wall here i disagree
and okay i will clarify and i have may i
add i also was ready to champion this
hopper and i still am i think you could
you got hopper potential in here but
right now you're pulling this double
cross
if i may ian is it true you want to be
hopper but you got typecast as yuri
yeah that did happen okay okay and so is
it possible
you know that if if cam's been writing
for you to be hopper which is debatable
obviously i'm hopper so that whole
you're not hopper that whole thing is a
little ridiculous
and i'm sorry ian's hopper see there's
this is a very contentious typecast
across the board regardless i'm
obviously hopper but regardless
um dustin
now
regardless in
um
that is interesting is it possible that
that you cameron feels betrayed he's
been he's been working on you to be
hopper and yet you put him in jonathan a
betrayal perhaps working the campaign
he's making it out to be is such a
non-campaign i don't okay you've you
have my back a little bit we had a
little bit you're still hopper dude okay
so it can be two hoppers that could be
hopper
hr
uh
when he originally said steve he did not
make the distinction that it was the
scoops ahoy
steve i would love to wear that scoop
can you agree with this a.b okay yes i
will say this initially started ian
wasn't even in the picture i walked up
and i was like oh we're being assigned
roles again we should all participate
who did you guys assign me i go i don't
know who i'd be steve and cam flipped
out he's like
that's that's not the case that's not
the case
i never get any say in who i am
hold on everybody go ahead and finish
your thoughts okay i just want to say
and then after i had this initial
conversation before ian was even in the
argument the girls say well if you want
to be steve then you'd have to wear
something like the chips ahoy outfit are
you okay with that and that was the
first time it came up and was like yeah
i'll do that so he was already in motion
before the chips ahoy thing that is true
can i say put forward it's a little
egotistic hold on
a little egotistical for you both to be
putting yourselves forward as steve
perhaps perhaps
i i said it like in a question i'm like
i don't even know of course you would
say oh i'm steve right the pocket he
said after seeing how much it means to
cam and ask him i've been writing for
him to be steve since i'm betraying him
a little right now so why don't why
don't you just put forward that you're
dustin or you know i literally said i
never they want to make me look good
let's we can debate that i was like you
guys never let me get any cool or funny
character i asked for either will or
barb at this point that's all i want one
of those maybe maybe may i also add they
were going to cast you as billy and you
were against that completely because i
wasn't going to be the user or something
i don't see i just think i i'm with both
you guys i think cam is being a little
forward but also i agree with kim that i
feel like we all should participate in
uh choosing who we're gonna be maybe
have a group discussion i'm fighting for
what's right you know who do that steve
all right well regardless olivia's input
here so regardless um
yeah olivia how did it because so ian
says that you by no authority vested in
you proclaimed cam to be steve did you
make that proclamation
theater kid she knows
yes i i would like to believe that i
think that i was present at the origin
conversation where this all started
because we were talking about
someone being bald and someone being
bald on stranger things and then we were
like oh my god what a great idea and
then i said something along the lines of
like who would i be and then i was like
oh
and then sam and i think i don't
i think sam and i were like robin the
whole thing started between me and
olivia yeah and i was like oh my god the
scoop's ahoy outfit and my brain
obviously showed me cam in the
scoopsahoy outfit because
that makes sense to me
but if anybody else wants and and i very
quickly posed that idea to cam and i
said would you want to wear the scoops
ahoy outfit and he said i would love to
and then i think the conversation that
av is talking and then at what point did
you enter this conversation and be like
yo what's going on here ian
i'm saying that
no you are so off
at the time
cameron was put putting forth i'm like
the macho chad of the office and that's
why i'm steve shirtless badass like
right
sleeves cut off
that is me just saying thank you abe
thank you
hold on i got a hairy chest like steve
too so i think that's that that works
too so do you see yourself as steve in
terms of like the are you the ladies man
i mean like there's characteristics
there cool you're a hero
i don't i don't see any of that but you
know i think i'm willing to fight for
what's right i drove ian around i drove
in home yesterday you know who does that
in the show steve yeah
certainly there's certainly a lot of
characters that embody that quality yeah
i think jonathan byers actually is
pretty good at doing that yeah sure i
remember driving someone home for a few
months yeah but i don't consider myself
well guys i think at this point there's
really no
we have three people here who see
themselves okay steve here's the thing
i'm obviously i mean guys this
enough are all three steves prepared to
wear the scoops ahoy outfit that's what
i'm asking i love cam too much i will
never be steve stop baby you want to be
steve i don't i don't i absolutely will
not actually we're gonna do a pull we're
gonna decide and the results is binding
i have a photo if you want to bring it
up that is the definitive casting of the
crew no we're gonna do this whole show
it's a nice try again no it's it's real
i think the poll is worth showing i mean
the uh we're gonna do a definitive pull
and the results are binding do you all
agree to this
between ian cam and av to be steve i
don't want to be steve
i wanted to be hopper looking at it i i
think ian should be hopping right so who
do you think should be steve then
i don't even think if you show my
casting i don't think anyone is steve
there's no steve no
i'm steve you're not steep
you're dusty you're dusted you're
dusting stop saying that i like dust i
mean dustin's cool and stuff but i like
dust
stop saying that let's just talk about a
little bit before you start saying who i
am look i will concede that if cam wants
to be scoops ahoy steve
he can be scoop's hoist thank you so who
wants to be steve here a b cam and then
i
it's okay you said it
interesting yeah
just to make it interesting so ian
you want to be hopper not steve no i
don't want to be steve i don't want to
be yuri
i hear yuri you are shooting i don't
want to be yuri all right let's take the
pole then um
ian
cam
and a.b who is steve i thought you want
to be steve too no i don't want to be
steve
i'm obviously not steve i'm not even
going to [ __ ] pretend like i'm steve
i just don't for the love of god if i
don't get steve i think it should be for
the love of god don't make me jonathan
it should be between a b and c
or well maybe maybe a better poll is who
is cam hold on yeah do who is cam who is
kim is it steve or is it jonathan
orwell no come on no
cameron cameron the results are binding
okay mike i mean let's if we're really
going to cast him cast him he'd be a
great mike i think which one's mike the
main goal part
i did think that also
okay okay so let's add mike i'm willing
to be anybody but the buyers like you
and that hawaiian shirt with the
little spinny top guys the result is
going to be binding here we have we have
mike
jonathan
and steve who do you guys see cam as and
this is binding cameron you agree to
that
yeah we gotta we have to resolve this
i agree to it i agree with you thank you
thank you all right so you also should
show ian's typecast at some point we
will yeah we will
and i'll pull up this image after this
so cameron we're going to resolve this
now via the democratic process and ian
you're going to agree to this as well
i agree can we shake hands on it shake
hands yes look at this this is human or
mike yeah could we also do a poll if i'm
yuri or hopper
we could also determine this yeah we can
do that right
good shake but when they vote they
should keep in mind the scoops ahoy
outfit i would say yeah because it would
be so
cute baby you're the slowest pull enter
of all time i'm not doing it love's
doing it i love doing it sorry love
you're doing great
you say sorry me too
thank you
all right here's the poll
um
what are you guys doing guys calm day
come on guys we should resolve in
conflicts over here all right so so um
we have the results here
who is cam get your votes in is he
steve
john
or mike get your troops ahoy steve
scoopy steve get your
get your votes in this is this is
binding now
okay now what do you think's the result
going to be cameron
the demogorgon
the demigorg i don't think that was an
option i'm just kidding uh hopefully
i don't know yeah well it's coming in
you're actually at 59 percent steve
thank you thank you chad i love the chat
and can we do one for ian yeah we'll do
one for you
so cameron actually cleaned it up i
think the people agree
people love cameron camily runs deep and
if the people have spoken i have to
agree with them yeah i mean it's
democratically elected steve
i got good news for you too buddy the
people love you they they will [ __ ] me
over
well let's see so so uh ian wants to be
hopper
the pinnacle of masculine yes energy i
see the man yes
or yuri
the little scumbag freak
all right are we getting that ready love
is that you
yes sir all right so so these are
binding so cameron congratulations you
are steve thank you very much chat
thanks for watching which we love for
you
real quick can i point out my uh gamer
sub bottle matches my shoes oh that's
sick i love that bottle oh that's nice
all right so the votes are coming in is
ian hopper or yuri it's close at the
moment i don't want to spoil it [ __ ] me
i know i don't want to spoil it for you
ian but
it is close so
what this should be a blowout for hobby
this is binding it's not going to be a
blowout guys please get your votes in
now if you're passionate about this and
it's hopper camily is tainted the
democratic process
come on man what are you wait
about the fans yeah so ian um i think
you'll be happy to find out 55 say your
hopper what so everyone's having their
dreams fulfilled here today
you guys both came out pretty clean on
this one huh awesome there you go is
that nice you guys feel good i feel
great i feel good you both got your
dream characters this this was really
nice i feel great that's nice who's ab
going to be
well let's open the casting thing that
you that we put how did you decide on
this type casting this was just things
that felt right to me
okay so this is from the mind of ian
yeah
okay so
abe is
this psycho brother
dan is out that makes sense
interesting all right all right
ann is hopper of course i'm dustin
dustin he's that's probably the easiest
one i think to determine cameron is
jonathan which is disproven here we've
disproven that i mean these ones are
easy olivia's what's her face and rob
sam is what's her face
my ass by my wife is bob newby
yeah i mean i love it it's a personality
it's the personality okay exactly i got
okay ian i got beef with this man i i
knew zach was gonna be unhappy
hold on hold on this is right on zach no
it is not yes it is bro
democorgan bro ian did i not ride for
you for hopper wait who do you want to
be i wanna i feel i'm [ __ ] eddie
oh eddie so we can do a pull on that one
a conflict resolution on that one ian
what the [ __ ] dude
i'm sorry i i had to be a little bit of
a yuri when making this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
well okay
one beef is resolved the new one is born
and also me i don't want to be bob newby
well actually
lena if i may defend this choice
bob has a pure soul he's helpful he's
dependable he's the man he dies
that's that that's beside the point
i think personality wise
this fits and it's a high compliment to
you you know well how about chrissy
cunningham nobody use her oh my god i'd
love to be so cute yeah the little
cheerleading outfit oh a sam walker i
said that sam said chrissy and i said
you want to make lena
the person who runs to the monster and
dies immediately you're not chrissy i
feel like that was a bit of a she was
like from the monster first of all
i feel like lean is more naked
right
nc i'll take you over you're bob lina
you're bob
like i could just put on anything and
call myself bob like you're not you're
not chrissy chrissy's a mess you know i
felt like chrissy would have been a
disservice to you lena and your
character bob has a heart of gold that's
why that's why i made the decision i'm
bob i'm team bob i want to be part of
this hidden council that's what i want
to do we're obviously going to have to
throw a lot of these to the audience
zach hold on one second you [ __ ] me
dude well
whoa hold on zack you were out of town
they said i should be eddie and i was
like zach deserves eddie [ __ ] ask
olivia eddie's not even on the board he
just got straight up
all right guys hold everybody pipe down
sam is
lena is that his name sam bob yeah
because he's sam and lord of the rings
yes love is vechna that's interesting i
mean i see the physical resemblance
certainly i like it love's also kind of
like a robot you know
one is a robotic character you know i
think it's fitting calculating i think
it's fine i don't really care if that's
much and ela is nancy which i think is
is very appropriate now that that was
also uh just to explain my bob decision
a little more i was gonna put nancy with
lena
but then i added
ella at the last minute and then i
wasn't sure what to do
is nancy yeah yeah
who's the mama well i'm just curious
when lena asked for chrissy and nobody's
chrissy how did you get bobby i do have
chrissy doesn't make sense go ahead lena
because well she gets haunted by
nightmares and i you know i have the
same issue not you know in the same way
but i also get haunted by nightmares
what kind of nightmares do you get oh i
have they're pretty similar
i do a lot yeah almost every night what
do you wake up screaming yes she beats
me up sometimes but yeah he does say i i
have like elbowed him a few times but
even when my sister and her friend were
spent the week with us they were like
surprised when i sleep like i how do you
describe the av the noises i make
the noises i don't know they're all over
the place i'm like freaking out in my
sleep yeah i constantly do that in my
sleep they were telling me when i was
can i ask you some questions about that
sure are you afraid to go to sleep at
night where you're like dreading it no
no not at all most of the time i don't
even notice it this is just from what
abe tells me you don't remember them the
dream yes i do sometimes because like
sometimes they just feel so real and but
i know that i'm dreaming and i try to
force myself to wake up like i literally
try to get my eyelids to open
yeah just to end the nightmare and and
do you recall what your dreams are of
i get a lot of michael myers um
nightmares um but then other than that
like a lot of like end of the world type
nightmares um i see yeah those are the
most common
well that is interesting that is
certainly a likeness there but i think
you're bob and i stand by that
i i will concede if you want to be
chrissy i only didn't put you with
chrissy because i thought
as i said the character got shafted
pretty quickly in the season and i
didn't want to put that on you but if
you embrace that character and
no she's
just kind of gets owned everybody loves
bob lynn i kind of see lena as steve
oh stop it weird dudes resolve that one
we're not going back now
ian we can't do steve again i think well
i think everything's been resolved right
at this point no no no no no no no no
okay works for me
all right okay so zach
we need to do a pull on zach and lena
and i've even talked about mine zach
could also be dustin
dude he could be dude i am so eddie come
on
all right let's do is zach what's this
guy's name eddie that's argyle that's
argyle do argyle
the pizza guy stoner
eddie
eddie the rock star eddie the rocker or
dustin argyle live at the troubadour why
do you [ __ ] me ian hold on the people
will vote is that second number zach and
this is binding i just want to remind
you guys that whatever
is the result of this
you have you agree to stand by zach no
what
absolutely [ __ ] not these guys
already got their dream casting how are
you going to go against the will of the
people ian i rode for you dude
such a camp
zac this is binding fine
zach's giving actually you know what do
you not want it to be binding you can
decide i want to be eddie yeah exactly
bro no it's not binding so you're not
eddie see that's what happens when you
don't trust all people
yeah overwhelming people are saying
eddie and but zach doesn't doesn't trust
you guys he doesn't want to be oh my god
so we're going to give him dustin nope
eddie it is
you said it's not binding i didn't say
that i said is it binding you said
absolutely not did anyone else hear that
come on we're having a good time it's
all good timing jokes
it's an old timey joke ethan yeah so so
what isaacs eddie costume going to be
he's just going to walk in the leather
jacket that he wears everything he's the
same outfit there he goes so he's ready
long hair
it's the [ __ ] issue here
i don't know isn't it fun to dress up as
someone else all right so zach
zach is eddie
thank you thank you it's not binding no
thank you people of the world we live in
a democratic society thank you so much
we live in a society we live in a
society we certainly do i i zach i'm so
i picked this one because frankly trying
to get you to participate with this
segment was like pulling teeth
i kept saying i need i need arguments
for this segment he goes i don't have
any arguments with anybody dan and i
spoke about zach argues with everyone
all the time when we need right about
everything we need to be [ __ ] on your
toes when we need him to argue for a
segment he's like i actually have no b
for issues with anyone this sounds like
an hr issue on its own yeah
i'm zen zack okay yeah uh when the one
day we need you to be argumentative zach
you're zen so i picked this to the
ticket he's a contrarian he's whatever
you don't need yes yeah
well said
all right well he's jonathan whatever he
is eddie i mean eddie sorry so let's do
lena next we just got to get to the root
of all this we have
samwise
gamgee or chrissy basically right
[Music]
so here we go
only bob and chris you know what to do
yes you guys know what to do
lena is rocking the vote ladies and
gentlemen is it only bob and chrissy
that's it now i no i don't think it's an
insult but i really think you're bob and
i don't me and i think and i mean that
in the nicest way possible that is
lovely i mean i'm not nothing against
bob but also like
aesthetically what's very there's
nothing distinctive about him
costume wise
what if you dress as christmas doesn't
matter know that you're bob
it's not soul dude it's about the soul
the essence
so the votes are coming in
let's see the people this is binding
lina so
[Music]
oh yeah the people voted chrissy people
really not people are really
[Music]
you guys are nice man you guys are
delivering the results
requested results this is really
something now there's really only one
left there's me yeah
who do you think you are oh [ __ ] i don't
know dustin obviously i'm either i'm
either
steve obviously
i'm not being the racist dude just put
that out there
racist yeah billy's a [ __ ] racist
oh yeah maybe doesn't want to be billy
either so i see um you want to vote you
want to do it we can contest it
surprising nobody's contesting dan being
hell no because that just is right
it just is yeah yeah al saves our asses
all the time that's dan
he saves us plus it'd be so funny to see
him in a dress dan in that hospital gown
putting his hand out like stop so
either i am
oh you guys are saying i'm papa that's
cruel stop
that's [ __ ] up why would you guys even
say that
so either i'm obviously steve the badass
chad who gets all the girls and it's
charming and
that's ian see i still ride for you
brother
well the people are going to speak on
where were you on i mean zach where were
you right now oh [ __ ] you i always said
you were steve i didn't hear it once
guys guys guys please we got to focus
so either i would say i'm
hopper steve i think you're dustin or
barb probably who's barb
mr clark he would be a great barb mr
clark is also chloe who's mr clark let
me type that i don't know all these
names you guys know mr clark it's mr
clark was the teacher the first season
who like showed them the line and how
they can get to different dimensions
you're a leader you're thought
uh leader papa's in the house
he's not this black dude is he no that's
the guy with the mustache
i mean sure whatever i think i think
barb search barb
papa's in the house
barb
i don't know who this is
rip barb dude justice for barb
who's barb i'll be [ __ ] barbara
deserves justice
well steve and nancy were getting on bob
barb was a hey what about the um what's
the kid the boyfriend of the redhead
girls
uh lucas little sister
oh billy no luke is his little sister
little hacker us max
no no no no she's in the the hell fire
club oh
what's uh
uh lucas's little sister lucas
little sister
erica yep yeah i'm feeling maybe erica
for you and and specifically just that
i'm a little girl
[Laughter]
no i'm feeling erica doesn't do that you
could also be winona ryder
we'll not be doing blackface by the way
just a disclaimer
just i mean if cam could be steve you
could be erica
wait who's the airport
great joke dude
no wonder nobody laughs at him
let's go
that's steve energy right there
that you are steve bro damn you proved
me wrong you are steve man all right so
so what's my poll i don't know uh hopper
steve i could be 11 too i'll take that
um um i could be the uh
the cool jock that wants to kill
everybody what what if you're vekna just
throwing that out there
i don't see the vector personally
i'm back now
oh okay
um
sorry abe i love you
okay so erica steve hopper dustin
stephen
yeah
yeah obviously i'm hopper but go ahead
no one's been wolfhard either yeah
and not dustin's not an option i like
dustin he's cool smart dustin is funny
charming for sure
charismatic cool
great guy
uh but
i guess you should add papa too i don't
know why people are saying papa that's
[ __ ] up
wait kill the poll kill the pole we
gotta add it
i voted erica
all right stop dustin is winning all
right now dude all right you guys are
[ __ ] lame it's like it's dusty why
you guys hook everyone up on me
democratic uh decision
stupid at lamos
do papa versus dustin i'd rather be papa
papa rules
papa bless all right
papa's a monster dude
all right we'll do one more here papa
versus dustin see where the where the
chips fall for me
yeah but obviously i am hopper
everyone's just doing a joke here on me
it's a bad poll
it is a bad pull thank you love
all right one more one more papa vs
dustin
and we'll see where the chips fall okay
papa's paw it's close you guys want me
to be papa
you want me to be the psychopathic
maniacal freak he's got a great hairline
too that turns me on okay that's a good
point he does have a really good
hairline that is very it's narrowing
papa versus dustin it's a closer
who do you want to be ethan like if you
if you could choose who would you want
to be
no i don't think i'm hopper
um if i could answer honestly
[ __ ]
honestly
i feel like we're missing some
characters too here i i don't i can't
picture everybody
honestly i don't know
but the people think i'm
papa yeah erica i want to be erica but
you guys didn't give that to me i'm the
only one who got [ __ ] here i got an hr
issue with all you people at home why
everybody get the person they want and i
don't get erica
i get papa the psycho
okay papa wins
that's pissed
so sucks dude papa's in the house
everyone is resolved right except a b
right
who
who do you want to be
who do you want to be i mean i don't
will maybe or barb
something fun
i could see you being will honestly it's
not that bad what's your hesitation with
billy
he's a racist
just like you man
[Laughter]
and you know billy's just like you know
like like strong and
good looking and
okay now you're fishing for compliments
you know it's not you be victor creel
it's not fun all right last one guys and
we gotta close the book on this
is abey someone in jail with no eyes the
racist dude is he racist what's racist
about him dude he was telling max not to
hang out with lucas he said a certain
type of people you shouldn't be hanging
out with oh okay i can't see that
or i guess i forgot about that so
a racist uh
bully freak
is his name bidly
billy or
uh uh what was it like this kid do you
want to be this kid
yeah do you want to be will do you want
to be will yeah dude
come on lady just do it for the show
just do it for the show i see the vibes
i see will let's do the pull we got to
move on guys this is a hr disaster
thank you for the gifted covid related
oh this is cover related thank you for
the gifted
hello
sorry guys uh you said sorry guys but
lena is our nancy
you're our nancy lina we love you
what about ela
yeah i think it's ela
for nancy
all right amy you got will you just talk
i'm the only one that gets [ __ ] here
you just tell the audience what you want
and they vote for you
all right abs will all right thank you
everybody i am the only one left with
conflict here but thank you thank you
guys let's trust fall but wait who i
trust following you the good news here
is that a b or sorry ian and cam have
really i feel come to a happy
a happy close here very happy thank you
chat
why don't you both trust follow each
other you probably put down the
[Music]
you want to hold the gamer stop
okay all right
wait no no no you catch him and then you
guys switch
all right what are you talking okay
[Music]
oh that's trust
that was beautiful switch that was
really beautiful you guys
don't look back
oh yeah he didn't he got you he's got
you man he didn't let you fall a little
bit
people are saying i'm murray
now
guys
make up your mind
basically i'm just the dumbest lamest
characters
period
ugly
free
you guys basically just calling me a
freak
no dustin's a sweet kid he's beautiful
dustin raw yeah justin is a great he's
the best character he's a beautiful soul
he really is which is why you're so
excited
but i'm not dusting anymore on papa oh
right a polar opposite
what are you just gonna wear a suit
i don't know at least i got the hair for
it you need to wear a suit and tell dan
what to do all day
and he's close and he has to call you
papa basically the only difference is
i'm not wearing a food wait with me is
uh 11.
do you have to calm papa i see i guess
and you gotta call him daughter i
haven't seen the later seasons of the
show so i don't know who you are daddy
what the [ __ ] you waiting for that was a
good season great season
i just daddy
i thought the third season sucked and i
i got out of it so okay i haven't picked
it back up yet yeah
all right up next this is a lot of
conflict here zach and me apparently i
don't know why i'm beef
i i wanted to throw out there if you
wanted to get to these other stories
today we might need to save these other
beefs for another
session because we have been going for
three hours already okay yeah let's do
these on maybe on monday because we
still have zach versus me dan versus me
so apparently i'm just gonna be whoop
throwing in the tree i don't necessarily
know
i was gonna talk about that when mine
came up because i i don't
i don't really have any beef to to
resolve with you
what was it gonna be
uh
well that was actually just like kind of
a last-minute thing my i was going to
call out zach for what iam was talking
about earlier the fact that he was
dragging his feet and he didn't want to
argue with anybody
but then he finally gave in and
he does have an argument for you ethan
so it it became kind of mood at that
point let's get along with everyone i i
am the zen master i i don't got our
issues with nobody okay fine so we have
so basically just me and zach then yeah
is that could we save this until um
yeah that's okay that's fine yeah okay
in the interest of getting to more
stories what's up tater tots
yo let me get some where's your daddy
let me get some i love tapes in the chat
over on tick tock
big daddy tate
let's go it's your girl
it's your girl all right so moving on uh
we got basically i want to look at
austin mcbroom his fight was put on by
triller you [ __ ] like that [ __ ] i
love it so i'm not pulling any clips
why or wait i ain't pulling clips
well we're not [ __ ] with trilla i
don't know what to do because there are
clips here
there's just one clip there's one clip i
don't think it's worth it
he's how's he gonna sue me for showing
this i mean he did once before
there's that
i'll just scroll through it yeah you
look you can see how empty the seats are
basically
i mean this is like a 20 000. oh that's
that one's just a cell phone video
that's okay that's fine
yeah so this is a 20 000 seat arena it's
empty bro
empty there's probably a thousand people
in there
and half of them are the production crew
this dude said i had more people at my
dog's birthday party
here's a tweet showing the empty seats
oh my goodness dude
yo
there is nobody there
uh here's austin's yeah we didn't
realize it was being run by trailer but
i'm sure this was a financial disaster
right like it have to be it has to be i
mean i love that triller ran this man
that's just my favorite
ryan cavanagh knows how to do it
fight by trailer the man knows how to
make money
another like 20 million down the drain
from his fresh 200 million investment
round drive angry drive angry indeed
yeah but the best part about it was
basically that
uh he got absolutely [ __ ]
dominated i mean absolutely destroyed
i think people were actually worried he
got injured
he definitely seemed to be concussed
i read somewhere that he went to the
hospital afterwards but
this influencer fighting stuff is
actually it just shows how dangerous it
is because this guy gibb i think
really could have or did seriously
injure him
i can show this because this is like a
cell phone you think
yeah as long as it's not in the official
broadcast it's
it was from tick tock
and uh yeah it's not official broadcast
yeah so um guys if you want to see the
whole fight obviously
you can go pay for it and watch the
whole thing this is for uh you know just
report i'm just trying to report the
news here i mean you know current events
and stuff so uh here's just a short 20
second clip from this very long
hour-long
event hours-long event
um
yeah and he knocked him down what's
crazy is that the ref is kind of insane
he kept it going he got knocked down
like five times
look at that dude
that was a kill shot right there man
that's brutal
so
gabe actually super impressive
the thing that made it even better do
you have that picture austin knocked him
down first
i think gibb was just unbalanced and
fell over
and he's standing over him like muhammad
ali thinking he's like the [ __ ]
do we have that photo [ __ ] him up you
can find it i know what you're talking
about because it makes his defeat that
much sweeter really it does
um
look at that dude yeah austin looked
horrible like
i think austin beat bryce hall and
thought he was the [ __ ] and i don't
think he prepared much for this fight
but here's all five of his knockouts
we're not going to show
the video knockdowns the knock downs i'm
not showing the video because because
ryan you can suck my fat [ __ ] tiny a
fat butt also tiny jewish [ __ ]
you know
so here you got knocked down once
twice
blood boiling three times
four times
five times yeah dude it was a massacre
it really was
a massacre i read something that said
you could literally hear on the stream
catherine mcbroom's like blood curdling
screams every time he would get knocked
down i would be scared
no he i that's
i think that's the biggest beating i've
seen since fouseytube got his face
pushed in by
you mean a few weeks ago no no the first
one was the way it was the first time
that happened i felt worthless this is
worse than fousey's recent loss honestly
i felt ugly
yeah i wish i could show you guys the
videos but i'm just i'm trying to knock
it i'm already got like three lawsuits
going and
just trying to chill a little bit on
that
only two now
right
well we'll we're waiting to see if
andrew tate sues me oh right okay
i feel like i we would have heard by now
maybe i i don't know maybe he's taking a
minute to draft i mean he's a crypto
attorney probably doing a lot of
research on what we're trying to define
passing the bar right now yeah he got
my neck exactly
but um
pretty cool especially considering when
you see
yeah oh wow this is a super i can't i
res photo fine high res i mean thank you
bro i can't find it i've been looking
this looks like a frame from uh mortal
kombat 1995.
no one no one cares about this it's all
yeah there's not a ton of media coverage
well it made it that much sweeter you
know i didn't feel bad for austin at all
because like i said he knocked him down
in the first round and he's like what
what i'm gonna [ __ ] you up like and it
just got massacred after that man idiot
yeah so that was good that was pretty
entertaining
i think everybody was happy about that
um
yeah it was reported that mcbroom went
straight to the hospital to get his dome
checked out
it was supposed to be at the crypto
arena
then it moved to the bank of california
stadium an even bigger stadium
so that they could have a thousand
people there
interestingly philip defranco took this
opportunity friend of the show in skinny
legend
to tap dance on austin's grave bro
he came out with some crazy receipts
he's got beef with austin mcbroom and
well i'm here for it
like i said i'm here for it
exploited his audience and family that
way because i mean this man wanted to
fight me for three million dollars more
like three cents but also for being
honest ksi went so easy on mcbroom
compared to the rest of the internet and
i understand why the internet would
react that way because i mean he's he's
a villain whether it be all the cocky
[ __ ] he was saying to give before
the fight or if you want to talk about
quality of character stuff people
looking at how he's exploited his
audience and family regarding audience
why so many people have called him a
scammer you know a number of those
things are connected to why i'm feeling
so petty right now but i don't know if
i've ever probably talked about this in
addition no i got suspended on tiptop
no
let's go you cannot go live
as a host from 9 21. i've essentially
been banned from twitter i've
essentially been banned
when i got
live access revoked for bullying and
harassment what on earth
simon cowell maybe
commentate w commentate w l
l three l three bullying and harassment
i wish they'd give me more what the
simon cowell put in a complaint oh you
weren't going to human
twitter's a rat hole
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] dude i didn't feel like i
was bowling anyone i barely said
anything about tate i think it's because
you said lena was bob
um
yeah okay that could be right i think
it's because ab made me fall over that's
true that no one cares about that i
think it was because the talking about
simon
you think simon i can't bully simon he's
a powerful man
very powerful man that was a joke
a lot of people hey this says i got 97
more views
than hosts with similar following check
us out
unbelievable the simon sends his regard
average watch time 58 seconds let's go
50 is super engaging wow i think that's
a lot for tick tock
well it's also not the most riveting
content when it's just
they probably can't hear anybody but you
it's horrible you can't see the screen
it's horrible
that's horrible
or the yeah the tater tots just
masturbate what does this mean it says
diamonds 41 thousand diamonds what does
that mean
forty one thousand that's people giving
you
like gifts but isn't a diamond like one
penny yeah it's not yeah it is so what's
forty one thousand pennies
four hundred dollars you can check
actually is like for if it's if it
really is a penny yeah it's a penny yeah
you can check your back
and your tick tock wallet it's pretty
good yeah really 400 you guys
and then it says gifters 100 wait
i'm trying to figure out what you can go
to stream statistics and you're gonna
see exact exactly how much you made
thank you for the gifted thank you for
the gifted
yo this is pretty interesting
we had 151 gifters shout out
hello
hello
this is so interesting live center let's
see
um
i want to find out this how do i find
this out diamonds
gifters [ __ ]
live analytics let's see
somebody's saying the tick tock comments
got flooded with hateful tater tots
right before it was blocked over the
tater tots rep
for who
you know what i mean they i think i just
got mass reported by tater tots
it could be i i absolutely think that's
what it is dude i just i can't get a
break on tick-tock man
it sucks
i love tick-tock that's the shame of it
it's a dog [ __ ] platform dude
it's socks i love it i can't figure out
how to figure out how much donations i
got there but okay guys wait go go to
your profile tab on the bottom right so
not in the live center no no no no okay
so profile yeah uh then go to the top
right of that with the three lines
yeah creator tools uh go to settings and
privacy oh settings and privacy and then
go under balance
and that should tell you how much that
was a very intuitive place to have it in
the privacy tab yeah what
it says
and it'd be under gift revenue dude live
gifts it says
288 bucks dude wow it's
you know what i'm gonna do with this
guys
i'm gonna convert this all to coins
and then give it all to zach next time
he's live
oh that's very sweet of you i love
making it rain on zach when he's live i
appreciate that he goes live on tick
tock huh i thought he just did that on
instagram one night i was just on the sh
i was on the [ __ ]
and zach was live and i just i dropped
like fifty dollars and you get
so many times i was just [ __ ] tapping
that [ __ ] like crazy
his lives are great too he puts on a
full concert so thank you yeah thank you
yeah it was fun i liked it appreciate
that but uh 50 dollars from
ballers from thank you ethernet for many
years wonderful content
hello
i think it would be so cute for the dogs
to be demogorgs for halloween that i
love oh that's yup
actually simon cowell said this to
tick-tock
and i'm pretty sure this is what got us
banned for bowling
the x factor damn that's
just a good one
damn and that's how he was able to last
through the prolapse because he was
protected by the godfather
the x is where your body will be buried
cameron cameron walked in here this
morning and he's like he's like i'm
smart
i'm smart mike i can do stuff
all right anyway back to phil
to me thinking that he does a lot of
[ __ ] up stuff on the internet this
[ __ ] years ago when my oldest
was younger and i wasn't there he didn't
realize that this kid that he was
filming was my son trey but he saw this
crying child at a haircut was like
that's gonna be content and posted my
son to his story i forget if it was a
story or a snapchat and he shot it in
this way to be like look at this child
that's losing it and then look at my
angels mocking and filming my son
without permission while he was like
freaking out because he has a
sensitivity to sound and so that which
i've held inside since then is part of
the reason i'm so glad this scumbag got
dropped especially at a [ __ ] failure
of an event where the great majority of
people that are even aware of it are
aware of it because you've been [ __ ]
memed you loser
that's pretty slimy who makes fun of a
kid in public and the fact that end up
being phil's kid is crazy
um and also shout out ryan cameron for
hosting another disastrous [ __ ] event
but a loser that guys i just cannot
emphasize what a [ __ ] loser ryan
cavanaugh isn't it
he has never succeeded at anything
uh
no except
well repulsing women getting cucked
uh
getting blocked by natalie portman
getting blocked by natalie portman uh
drunk driving
right
bucky he's a two-time champ two-time
baby the two-time he's king of having
his own personal driver
right can't drive a car yep
and then
probably the pr i don't know this for a
fact but i would hazard a guess king of
holes in the drywall and his oh
maybe he's got to get in the ring yeah
um too much wine sorry king of wanting
to [ __ ] 14 year old natalie portman
right
i have an inappropriate relationship
were you able to find that video though
i was kind of curious to see it if it's
like out there of austin making fun of
phil's kid
we could blur phil's kids i looked a
little bit i was coming up totally
empty-handed i mean phil seemed to
indicate it he he wasn't sure if it was
a snapchat and if it was a snapchat from
like four or five years ago i mean that
[ __ ] is probably long gone but if
anybody out there in the audience uh
knows
of this being archived somewhere that's
super interesting phil well there you
have it love to see it
i hope that there's a conflict between
triller and him at least where like
ryan kavanaugh stiffs austin that would
be my favorite that'd be so
good and i'm sure it will happen frankly
if one of them does owe each other money
somebody's getting stuff for that behind
you i don't know who it is but somebody
who's going to live
okay so moving on finally
uh we've been going forever but i do
want to talk about there's been putting
on forever
dom dirty dom
at long just what it can eat made a
video about me
this man is still showing his face on
the internet can you believe that
it's pretty incredible stuff
um
here he is dominique exposes h3 and jeff
whittick
are you ready to be exposed i don't know
man i'm pretty nervous
this of course is dirty dom
former vlog member who
famously got
massively
uh
exposure after being credibly accused of
r wording a girl in a david dover blog
here he is
ladies and gentlemen a friend of a b
right friend of the show in a way
maybe he saw him on the street once i
met him once
you guys took a photo together right
before he was an artworker yep didn't he
like your pants
yeah i remember that he liked it yep
now but when you took that photo did you
know about the vidcon thing or no
no but i didn't know about the r word
no i'm kidding no i didn't know anything
no i'm just kidding i'm not accusing you
of anything
but okay here we go
brace yourselves guys ethan talk about
david dobrik and
for some reason this guy ethan keeps
making videos about him he's been making
videos about me for two years
i've met the guy right now
he just uploaded this like a last week i
haven't talked about you i haven't
thought about you in like a year since
the drama happened
well you talk about him with jeff with
jeff that's why he's okay okay yeah
yeah that's where this is coming from
okay okay
sorry i'll talk about you bro outside of
that i don't think you've talked oh stop
talking about me bro
dude you're an r word
shut up
you need to be on like a registry you
need to stop talking about me and go
talk to your neighbors
as is legally required of you
on a you know sex offenders registry
singh never had any bad exchanges with
him he was a very nice guy to me nothing
bad happened oh this is super weird wait
let me go some reason this guy ethan
keeps making videos about me he's been
making videos about me for two years
met the guy once in passing never had
any bad exchanges with him he was a very
nice guy to me nothing i have never met
this man yeah where is that i have never
met this man ever was he was he maybe
thinking of you maybe that just
no he wouldn't worry
you had a you met david once was he
there with the whole squad oh i don't
remember
i met david a long time ago at the
creator
yeah
event thing right i don't remember
meeting dom i mean i don't think don was
there it was just david david they
didn't invite the whole vlog squad it
was david and liza was there and i
already both i don't think even jason
was there oh jason was there jason was
there i don't know what elsa could have
been
bro i have never [ __ ] met you but
even if i did like this is like yo i met
him once
he didn't talk [ __ ] to me then
i can't believe this guy would lie
through his teeth i know i know it's
shocking but it's just such a weird lie
jeff whittake and ethan talk about david
dobrik and
what's funny but for some reason this
guy ethan keeps making videos about him
he's been making videos about me for two
years
met the guy once in passing never had
any bad exchanges with him he was a very
nice guy to me nothing bad happened it
was this whole thing i was i was such a
nice guy to him that i've never met him
like
if he was that creator clash and i don't
remember and was maybe just like hey i'm
ethan i didn't even know who they i
didn't know anything about the vlog
squad even there i barely knew anything
about david dobrik
i don't i didn't i only learned about
this guy once the story came out i
didn't know anything about it but he
keeps
trying to push a [ __ ] narrative of me
online and bullying me online
jeff too jeff said a bunch of [ __ ] up
mean things when all yeah dude
you're right i'm trying to blow you
offline you need to get offline
if what if bull if bullying an r order
to get off youtube is is wrong that i
don't want to be right
or something
the [ __ ] went down and i never i never
said one bad thing about him i never
mentioned anything bad about him uh this
just shows how [ __ ] perverted his
thinking is it's like yo i never said
anything bad about you so how why are
you going to blast me for being an r
word it's like what does that have to do
with anything dude
yo this guy dirt this guy dawn was super
nice to me once so i'm just going to let
that r word slide
i even remember man he was he was one of
the guys that um
you know really pushed me to like
actually like take myself more serious
you know i remember we were at saddle
ranch one time this she's talking about
jeff uh this is probably the last time i
saw everyone and he was like i thought
he was talking about you i was like what
the hell
but his logic making no sense like yeah
you guys used to be friends before
the story came out i mean
that makes total sense he goes on he
says
he uh here he talks more about it i'm
just going to go to the best time stamps
possible
because it is a long video there she
wants to come into the room with me the
girl will call her susie the one that
did the allegations she comes into the
room with me and her friend comes into
the room with me right
we're in there we're drinking we start
you know doing our thing right
meanwhile you know the door keeps
opening david's looking inside jeff's
looking inside everyone from the vlog
squads look inside nick and tony is
looking inside you know if at any point
something weird was going on you don't
think they would have been like yo
what's going on this girl that's so
stupid bro
that why
the accusation is she's like passed out
drunk if she just laying there how they
gonna know if she's passed out drunk
so dumb bro
literally the worst defense i've ever
heard just passed out yo dom what the
[ __ ] are you doing you don't think would
have been a little they're in a dark
room what are they how are they gonna
tell but weird you know way worse how
how okay all right gets worse
according to jeff they faked the peeking
in thing
now i'm gonna be
super honest i know jeff's bestie
i'm not gonna accuse jeff of it maybe it
wasn't but i could totally see david and
others other dudes peeking in when
they're hooking up i mean that was like
the whole point of the night
i could totally see that happening but
regardless i don't i think it's totally
ridiculous to expect them to realize
that she was like passed out
black out drunk anyone would have felt
morally obligated to be like yo stop you
don't think her five other friends that
were there would have been like
hey our friend's unconscious we should
uh probably have you stop [ __ ] her
you know you don't think no no one would
have brought that up dude you're so he's
getting obligated
isn't he morally obligated to make sure
that the girl he's having sex with is
cognizant and willing yeah he says she
said
right right right right like from his
baby
this whole video is gross so angry he's
so guilty bro
yo why didn't they notice that she was
blasto if they
it's like you're so guilty dude oh my
god little sickos or something like i i
don't understand right
we're laying there the girl that's drunk
she starts falling asleep okay she
doesn't fall asleep busted ladies and
gentlemen we got him yep and he also and
she went and threw up afterward it's
like
she was passing out ladies and gentlemen
we got caught in dude
we [ __ ] got him
sleep midway through having sex right
she's not over there napping and i'm
over here penetrating her having the
time of my life i think her friend that
was there with her what did you think
she would be a little bit disgusted you
think she did say on the record she was
disgusted and panicking yeah also don't
you dare
describe
the r word that you performed on someone
though having the time of this life
describing it is so disturbing
oh my god
he basically [ __ ] shames her also later
in this video spoiler it
is the most frustrating thing i've ever
watched like i i'm boiling again
watching it yeah this dude's disgusting
man it's kind of insane
nobody's got his back i love that top
comment is this is literally gaslighting
yeah i'm glad i was i was wondering what
kind of comments i'd see but
funny to see you desperately clinging on
to whatever leftover fame you have from
david
dude you just said she was passed out
you don't think anyone that would have
peeped into the room at that time and
saw this unconscious girl and me they're
penetrating her while she's lifeless
[ __ ] hanging their dead you don't
think they would have thought something
was dude you are so [ __ ] guilty
oh [ __ ] this is wild this is kind of
gnarly actually
dom says the reputation of being in this
video is why she said that she was
r-worded oh my god
platforms you can imagine this girl went
to school the next day that this video
was posted and everyone's laughing at
her giggling at her oh there's [ __ ]
susie the [ __ ] that that slept with dom
and and had had a threesome with her and
her friend right it's [ __ ]
embarrassing dude you're going to hell
you're actually going to hell dude
pretty incredible stuff imagine imagine
her mom sees this video and she's like
what are you what are you doing like
this is this is the type of public image
you want to have how are you going to
get a job in the future if there's this
video out about oh you seem super
sympathetic to that why'd you [ __ ] do
it then
he's like yo obviously this ruined her
life anyway so earlier that night i was
trying to get five girls to come have a
fivesome with me
obviously everyone's gonna sledgehamer
afterwards you're so sensitive about it
why didn't why did you do it about you
right it's disgusting
her mom probably set up
disgusting
uh you were there bro i don't know if
you remember but you org like whatever
you think happened that night you
organized it in your brain
oh no it's not he literally put out a
post saying i'm trying to have a fight
but it's disgusting whoa
you should be in jail dude
wow
dude
it's incredible now i mean it's been so
long and then he's he's talking about it
now
i'm gonna kick you out of the [ __ ]
family for doing some type of dumb [ __ ]
like this this video didn't make this
girl look good okay you know she looked
like a [ __ ] college [ __ ] you know
dude
this is hard to watch as a guy i can't
imagine as a girl
i apologize olivia that i asked you to
do this
i wasn't even thinking i
if someone's
okay
i went through something similar to this
when i was 19
if that boy spoke about me like that
i don't even
i can't listen to him say [ __ ] like that
it's so embarrassing for him for
everyone involved it's just you are
violent
you are an r-wordist
you did that
no girl wants to come out and say this
happened to me
as much as everybody thinks that people
believe girls they don't a lot of people
do not
and it's very tough to come out and do
[ __ ] like this and sit and tell your
story
and he's [ __ ] all over it by going
back and calling her a [ __ ] it's like
you're he's going for all the cheap
shots also it's like it's not even he
hasn't even thought about what he's
gonna say
yeah this is [ __ ] nasty
i don't understand how i can say that
you're you were there
like
you were there
i mean this is the i guess he's kind of
he's he's part of tate university
where it's like girls are [ __ ] dudes
rule dudes are players
he's a freak
yeah i'm sorry olivia that's that's
pretty annoying i mean that's annoying
but it's not i'm sorry that's
infuriating
dude it's kind of a mask off moment for
a minute
i don't know he's
describing vividly the attack
that she recounted
it's it's so
it's so gross
over it dude
i'm shocked by this i'm sorry olivia
i mean
i can turn it off talk about
no it's fine
as long as everybody knows he's wrong oh
yeah oh yep even in his comments trust
me
this has 180 likes out of 10 000 views
there's 180 tate fans who are
loving this who are buying this
and even the comments are [ __ ] on
them
to put it i just reported it by the way
i don't know if it's better to to report
it or just to leave it up to show what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he is
but it'll be up forever people are
saying turn it off yeah we can turn off
we don't have to watch this
what a sick [ __ ] larry let me see if
there's any other good time stamps
thom says ethan never invited him on
okay
just just jumping past the uh
the victim blaming violent psycho
misogyny those girls are [ __ ] wrong
from the beginning and they're [ __ ]
framing me right
but i didn't that's that's that's my
mistake you know
you live and you learn
okay
still some victim blaming there i
thought i skipped it over did i go i
mean we you obviously had like a rough
interview right yeah and there was a
reason i was pressing there see he never
invited me for any [ __ ] interviews
why would i never once he's just give
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] do i want to talk
like like what would be the value of
talking to you there's already a victim
that's well corroborated like what would
be the actual journalistic value of
talking to you
you're just gonna deny it i know that
you're just gonna say it didn't happen
they're lying but like it's obviously
corroborated
um
yeah and i don't want to give you a
platform either and also it's like it's
not even about that one time you've done
this before
so it's like part of a track record of
behavior
it's like oh no no he's an art worker oh
no i don't want to hear from him he
never brought me on his platform so he
never gave me a chance to voice my
opinion right just completely [ __ ]
brushed me off yes
you got it man whatever
whatever anger you feel towards me
yes that's exactly what i did bro i said
this guy's trash
i brushed them off i said i don't want
to talk to you i said your perspective's
not valid or interesting
and uh everything you're feeling keep
feeling that because it's all true
and get off the internet bro
change your name move to a new town or
something
[ __ ] go to a you know he needs to go to
a monastery or some [ __ ] and like just
eat rice for ten years
think about [ __ ]
never did anything to this [ __ ] guy
you believe this [ __ ] was kind of like
stupid would you have to do something to
me for me to be not supporting you an
issue that we needed to get to the heart
of
but i think with you i've been you know
i've i
i have a lot of empathy for you i liked
you as a person and that's why we're
here today yeah
so
dumb he's so mad i'm glad you like him
bro i wish you liked me
yeah where's my [ __ ] em at the
[ __ ]
why do you here i am telling you and i'm
i'm sure you're gonna see this i have no
empathy for you you're scum you're a
demon
and
keep being angry because it's absolutely
right
you got it you nailed it bro
yeah i under i can understand from your
perspective it was probably a painful
and difficult to deal with like the
receiving end of that much well i
willingly came on the show because i
felt i had nothing to hide i'm not
ashamed of anything yeah and i said
what's the worst that could happen was
in the right state of mind at the time
no yeah
you know it was in and out of surgery on
meds
and it's you're asking me about a
situation three years ago now five i
don't remember what i said about dan or
a.b on you know
so yeah i wasn't prepared for that type
of thing and
i felt like i was the kid in making a
murderer you know
right you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
and i try to talk i didn't say anything
because i didn't want to say but i that
that analogy is not exactly perfect
because i wasn't um
i don't feel i was coercing him into a
confession you know
but i get i get his i get the sentiment
talk to you about it afterwards and
there was no door for us to even have
that conversation yeah anyway i don't
know where this is going but he later
says
something really funny
um
no one else would do that
and so
no one else would do that i literally
messaged him and
i had big nick message him because big
nick was just on his show right and he
messaged big nick back saying
oh i don't want to have him on the show
he has some some controversy about him
i don't really want to have him on that
would be a perfectly fine thing to say
when i went back and i was like what the
[ __ ] i don't remember talking to big
nick about
dom so this is the i went back and found
this dm exchange with big nick he said
hey dom spoke to me and wants to come on
your podcast kind of explaining how him
and dave were high school buddies and
then after the fame he kind of got
discarded
i was like bro go cry in your own
channel like this is so stupid
i think this must have been before the
allegations yeah this look what i said i
said who was dom
was he in his videos i've heard they
the name before are there allegations
against him or is that someone else
this was it
he was like yo i want to come on and
complain about how dave is not buddies
with me anymore
so not exactly what he described right
so he didn't even give me a chance to
[ __ ] big nick back saying
oh i don't want to have him on the show
he has some some controversy about him
i don't really want to have him on right
so he didn't even give me a chance to
[ __ ] speak my mind bro you're not
entitled to be on my show dumbass
you're not entitled to any attention
at all
the only tension you're titled to is
from the [ __ ] police officers
and a judge
yeah weird guy dude weird video
um
oh this is interesting
this sounds like a pretty compelling
argument here let's see oh my god i love
you how's life
these [ __ ] hollywood people are
[ __ ] bro
it's the bear like
i'm hollywood [ __ ] weasel or
embarrassed i'll tell you this
association forever i think it's [ __ ]
up
you know how people hold [ __ ] over
people's heads forever this was a
horrific crime actually that happened
but you didn't do it horrific [ __ ]
crime you believe this guy you know it's
a horrific crime all the [ __ ] in and
out burgers of this [ __ ] you know
what i mean
there it
[Applause]
ladies and is
batman bad
i'm gonna take down
all the videos relating to him right now
so true [ __ ] owned you so hard ladies
and gentlemen we got him yep so
i never even thought about it like that
i am a bit of a hypocrite to call him
out for r word because i do am fat right
it's our order but
i am fat right but damn you've been
slamming those double doubles my dude
yeah because the animal style is
comparable to art
totally
good job dom
good guy
[ __ ] what a guy what a guy
i'm hungry for in and out now i know i
could eat a double double right
dedicated to dom
get that that should do it's been very
painful for you
of course i apologize for all the
messages i've sent you afterwards
obviously a good guy you know dom
got his head on straight he's skinny
he's skinny so that makes him
pretty much right yeah
just consider that
yeah i do i do he asks ethan if he can
come on the show are you [ __ ] serious
bro i think i was an ethan i think i was
pretty clear about it but here let's see
his his uh
call to action here
okay that's good and then there's the
thing where like your body came to my
house do i i can't continue growing man
listen ethan if you're really serious
have me on the podcast bro let me come
and tell my side of the story because it
seems like you're just [ __ ]
roasting me till the end of time
yep and that's what it's going to keep
me
he can't be [ __ ] serious no dude he's
entitled to come on the show
oh my god i think i need to lose weight
before i talk to him though because i'll
be obviously yeah oh you don't want to
get back into a corner it's just not
it's just not a fair in fact debate
if i'm fat i love after a video of him
talking about how you won't have him on
the show he ends it with
so ethan if you're really serious about
having me on your show yeah
like these are my terms yeah
it would be interesting to eviscerate
him on the show but ultimately he just
struck he i think this kind of guy who
thrives on any attention good or bad he
basically just gave a play-by-play of
him committing the crime i mean i don't
know how much more we could get him on
he's such an idiot yeah he really is
we gotta won't bite all right
you promise you won't you promise you
won't r-word anyone here
sorry bad joke but yeah
but that's what i'm worried about dude
not biting
can we can we um
can we frisk you for gbt or whatever
that hb
frisky for ghb
you're such a weirdo bro you're [ __ ]
weirdo make sure to hit that like and
subscribe button too all right push the
[ __ ] in the algorithm all right don't
worry we won't yeah dutch yeah um
gives it away it really right away dude
i know von dutch who wears that [ __ ] now
i feel like we're glossing over the like
and subscribe a little too quick
i know
like for more content like this i think
ethan won't do it but he will yeah that
man
well i was kind of wanting to
touch on that i wanted to go the
comments
only 122 not a lot
and he's asking for support so let's see
this is gaslighting um
sometimes people learn from their snakes
and then sometimes this happens
bro this goes along with the birds and
bees talk even though a woman says yes
all the way through they can say no
whenever they want men have to watch and
know who their do their business with
very easy for things to turn in that
situation and have to be aware of this
possibility
uh
and that's the dislike
yeah i just checked it out with the
extension kelly says the way oh this is
a new comment this is from 10 minutes
ago i was a super trooper but shout out
kelly the way in which you describe
yourself assaulting her as the time of
your life is disgusting
closed out the video after that
good [ __ ]
oh this guy apparently i don't know if
ethan understands the internet that's
the comment if you know you know
we don't know can i read between the
lines do you have a guess ab
he's saying that you don't give a [ __ ]
and you're milking the drama oh okay
okay
bro calling ethan fat seriously
all right shout out to the super
troopers out there we love you
and that's it guys this has been an
absolute marathon how long we've been
going
we have been going for three hours 37
minutes who doesn't work with us
nobody knows nobody is this insane dude
we're doing three and a half hour shows
four times a [ __ ] week who does that
and that's that who can be entertaining
for that long to come here together as a
team to produce this high level of
content nobody
we have forty thousand viewers after
three after [ __ ] three and a half
hours it doesn't exist this doesn't
exist that's why we said and we need to
soundbite that zach
the more podcast in the world one
podcast in the world my man out of you
nobody's got a sound engineer who's 10
steps ahead like we look at that look at
that we're like the 90s bulls
absolutely baby number 18
r.i.p to number 18 by the way let's give
it up for bison who was behind somebody
actually
by the way everybody's going to go back
his killer never prosecuted because of
maritime law he was in international
waters wow
very unfortunate situation
number 18. no one else is
i don't follow i don't follow you slow
clap you're killing my vibe dude
maritime laws murder
i'm not following
okay so tomorrow we have a really fun
special episode
into the metaverse we're gonna pay our
respects at the 911 memorial oh my god
is there other people at the memorial
with you yeah i become a meta expert i i
can show you around yeah you can be my
guide
we have two now so maybe a b can be like
a little tour guide for by the way i've
met like four fans just randomly they
recognize my username oh really what's
your username it's just a b starkiller
okay and then someone was an ex-fan of
yours oh no you thought you met a fallen
fan we had a lightsaber duel on the
metaverse i told him to take back what
he said
thanks bro yeah i gotcha
kill it with the primer no he [ __ ] me
up i didn't know what i was doing but i
kept going i kept going for like a half
hour
um people saying without hassan
tomorrow is
the second leftovers that we're skipping
because hassan is
on a uh seemingly on a
tour of the whole country every time i
look at his twitter he's in another
place
next week leftover will be back
but tomorrow at one o'clock we'll be
we'll do the metaverse episode on friday
we got a big old boy with howie and
c-man what a time to be alive
oh and we have the second headset for
tomorrow so we can have
right the third yeah i could be the
camera guy
okay that's good
there's a world in the metaverse that's
literally just like howie's prolapse
anus
what somebody created that it's not
really that but a fan's the one that
showed me and it looks just like in his
i want to go there sucks you up yeah
i'll take you there but we won't come
back
i'll be a one-way trip
for the world this is yours truly all
right guys so we'll see you tomorrow at
1pm pst uh i will not be seeing you on
tick tock live because i'm banned
because all the tater tots couldn't
handle this level of alpha energy i
thought it was the territories it could
have been the simon cowell stands
they're strong
they're so sensitive we get like one
clip removed a week on the main tik tok
all right guys see you tomorrow
love y'all thanks for watching
number one podcast in the world